joe rogan has finally told his audience
sort of to vote republican
in his episode with aaron rodgers aaron
asks him you know what do you tell these
people you know who had their businesses
and lives destroyed by the lockdowns and
he goes vote republican then they both
laugh and then admittedly i laughed when
i heard it and then joe's like well they
were going to do it anyway you know a
million people switched to the
republican party i think in 2021 and
he's right
joe also made another really interesting
point in his show that 75 of tv
advertising in 2020 was pharmaceutical
companies
that explains a whole lot
so we got those stories about joe biden
he's calling trump supporters fascists
semi-fascism sorry doubling down and now
donald trump is calling for either a an
immediate redo of the 2020 election or
that he should be reinstated as
president because we learned the fbi
actively interfered in the in the
election by not doing their job i mean
they did so much they wouldn't
investigate hunter biden whistleblower
came out and said this because they
didn't want to they didn't want to
influence the election but then they
went to facebook and said hey here's
some russian disinformation watch out
for that which is actively interfering
and and violating 1a so there's no
excuse at this point and there's
questions about why they're going after
people over ashley biden's diary but
he's not a federal employee she's not in
government she's a private citizen who
left her book somewhere and the feds got
involved over this
something
dirty is happening we're going to talk
about all that plus much much more
before we get started my friends head
over to timcast.com become a member you
want to support our work we're going to
have a members only show coming up for
all of you but also it's a big week for
us we put out a song and uh it's done
really really well for those that aren't
familiar we release the song friday only
ever wanted
wanted only ever wanted on tim cast
records and um
thank you all so much for supporting the
song to everybody who bought it you're
you're really helping us the link is in
description below if we can get a
certain amount of sales we can actually
chart and the goal is
simply put out we here uh i'm sure many
other uh you know independent media
we're trying to force the cultural
establishment to acknowledge and and
we're also trying to invade their space
take over
what i want to do is
we want to create a parallel culture in
a parallel economy so that people won't
feel scared to say no over the cult
ideology that if they're like oh if i
speak up i'll lose my job well we need
to create spaces where people know there
will be industry available for them not
to mention we do music here we all do
carter engineered and produced this song
something that i wrote and uh it's just
something we wanted to make and i'll say
this too we didn't expect it we didn't
expect it to be trending to hit number
two and itunes i just was like we're
gonna start making music we made pop
culture crisis we made sales from the
inverted world we made chicken city and
to varying degrees they've been
successful and we weren't doing it
thinking we were going to be the biggest
shows in the world where you know
obviously we would hope if that was the
case
and i think there's a there's a bit of
unexpected backfire in the sense that
the song took off and did so well we're
getting a whole bunch of attention from
people who are really mad at us the left
these leftist commentators are really
attacking us over this and uh you know
what you know so be it this is what
we're trying to do and this is what we
get involved in so check out the song
only ever wanted it's our second release
our first official release under tim
cast records i guess we're calling it
with a band called tim cass i don't know
what i don't know what you want to say
but uh we also released will of the
people if if you guys really want to
support us the song is 69 cents it's the
cheapest you can make it we're not
trying to make money off this we're
trying to have an impact and we're
trying to build an industry for for more
bands for more music that can resist the
wokeness and succeed so
you know i'll also do this i'll shout
out tom mcdonald because he's got way
better music than we do all i want to
see happen is a space to be developed
around people who can say no to the cult
and have an impact and if you guys went
out and bought
fake woke by tom mcdonald did every
single person who watches this did he'd
hit number one in the billboard charts
i'm happy with that but i also know that
we're going to do what we have to do on
our end with what we can do and if you
want to support us link is in the
description below
so uh again smash the like button
subscribe to this channel join us today
joining us today we have drew hernandez
thank you guys for having me man i think
it's uh
interesting times
uh monkey pox is
all over the place people are having to
watch their backs literally uh i mean
the simulations shifting
all of a sudden the left loves the fbi
going after trump good times uh it's
refund the police here here we are again
yeah i love that they're like they're
like we're anti-fascist but support
federalized centralized law enforcement
going after people okay yep
here we are
all right uh i'm going to ruin you i'm
going to mess with your last name is it
buddhazone right butter zoning butter
sony i said boot yeah i'll be here man
thanks for having me yeah we'll
introduce yourself were you yeah i'm an
independent uh reporter and journalist
uh based out of dallas i've been
covering a lot of the drag shows
unfortunately in the area it's it is a
crazy time uh we got the left propping
up big pharma uh propping up these group
these uh you know these these crazy
people these drag shows so it's
interesting interesting interesting
stuff
uh hey everybody ian crossland here
happy to see you guys and i wanted to
mention a couple things before we get
started one is about the music that
we've been working on music and the arts
is kind of like there is competition in
the arts like who's gonna get number one
who's gonna get number two who's gonna
play on main stage at the grammys who's
not but at the same time it's the kind
of industry where you make each other
better the better music that comes out
the people listen to it then they get
more inspired they get more real and you
start to hear rock and roll like and
they were like why all these great
vocalists in the night early 90s in
seattle with this grunt scene why chris
cornell
um
what's his name uh eddie vetter and all
these phenomenal because they were
making each other better they were
seeing each other and inspiring each
other so keep doing that i love how you
said what's his name yeah what's his
name eddie better my hero that one guy
um
i've got it wrong you can't be
competitive it's about doing your best
true it's not about being number one
it's about doing your best it's about
elevating someone else to experience it
as well and then they'll you'll
automatically you end up becoming number
one because they love you so much the
second part is i want to apologize to
everybody that worked on breaking bad
the tv show talked about on friday and i
misrepresented the show
walter white was did you watch it no but
enough people that i trust have told me
walter white was trying to make money to
that when he died that he would have
money for his family he wasn't trying to
get money for the treatment i will say
it is it is a component the show was
pharmaceutical propaganda
we're talking about in 2020 75 of the
commercial space being pharmaceutical
companies i think breaking bad also is a
pharmaceutical propaganda piece and we
could talk about that later if you guys
want to real quick
it's not the main i'm watching it i'm on
season two i'm like i'm almost on season
three
it he he he tells there's people who are
gonna pay off his bills and he tells him
to f off so it's like kind of but not
really about that anyway we'll we'll
talk about yes
here before we get into our breaking bad
conversation again i have to read the
super chat real fast it's really short
it says only ever wandered is the joe
biden version which i love that's
wonderful thank you for that oh man
sheamus
jameis we need you only ever one wonders
yeah all right let's get going yeah all
right check this out from the post
millennial
vote republican joe rogan on how
americans can protect your freedom well
everybody knows that dr joe rogan is who
you go to for your political and medical
advice i'm joking by the way calm down
youtube and uh here's what happened joe
rogan and green bay packers quarterback
aaron rodgers got into it into the got
into the harms of covet policies in a
recent episode of the experience and
rogan took the opportunity to blast
democrats and give a boost to
republicans
vote republican he said in response to
roger's question about what americans
should do about it quote
no one who was alive today had ever
experienced a true pandemic and i'm
hoping that now that this is over people
are going to you know recognize that
some serious errors were made and not
repeat those that's the best you can get
out of it so what do you tell those
people roger said
vote republican rogan said rogers
chuckled that's what a lot of them are
going to do anyway more than a million
people transferred over the republican
party i think in 2021 alone but you know
you look at guys like ron desantis who
kept florida open and had some pretty
reasonable policies in terms of like
what to do about covet and you know he
mapped it on television full stop
desantis did not keep it completely open
they did shut down but eventually faster
than everybo than many others did reopen
there were a bunch of red states that
never locked down christine owen for
instance they threw a parade for her
he was widely criticized for this where
he was saying we need to protect our
elders we need to make sure that medical
care is available for those people and
everyone else should be able to do
whatever you want to do and protect your
freedom now this is the crazy thing
joe has taken the bold step of laughing
and telling people to vote republican
he's often said he was a liberal he's
defended all of that
he's like people call me right wing but
i'm a liberal and he is he's like he's
in favor of universal basic income
now he's telling people to vote
republican but i feel like it's not even
an endorsement of
the republican party i feel like the
overton window has shifted so far left
that it's it's almost like a rejection
and vote against the people that are
going so far liberal um i don't think
it's like you know a typical endorsement
of the party as a whole yeah there was a
uh this graph that we've showed a long
time ago where it's like where the
political parties are and they created
this this spectrum where it was economic
left and right and and um i think like
social justice left and right the
democrats were all extremely hyper
concentrated in racial and economic
socialist policy and the republicans
were spread out away from the social
justice stuff but varying from socialist
all the way to la fair capitalists
that was crazy gotta be careful about
calling leftism liberalism as well
because there is an idea of like
liberalism is you want to be free and
open with ideas and let kids kind of
explore the world but sexualizing
children is not i don't think that's
liberty i don't think that that's doing
justice to children it can warp them in
their later years this is this is i
think on par with what imagine noise
refers to as like up and down or
something
is it does he call it up and down i
think so like the axes yeah cause like
the the you know he talks about how
maybe maybe maybe maybe he doesn't say
it but he talks about how religious
zealotry is not left or right
it's it's it's idea it's something
different and if you've got people who
have a cult ideology that doesn't really
fit into any of these political spectr
like political sections or segments then
we got to acknowledge that it's not
liberal it's not left like jacobin for
instance they're socialists they're
leftists but they're pro free speech
they rag on the fbi all the time they
rag on the democrats and i'm like okay
cool you know i can respect that i guess
i don't agree with the socialism part
though so rogan's i think rogan's i mean
in the context of these statements he's
talking about the pandemic right he's
talking about the way that covid was
handled and i think a lot of people are
just fed up and they see through just
exactly everything at this point i mean
take a look at fauci's riding off into
the sunset in december apparently
they're shifting gears and shifting the
simulation politico is putting out
articles literally changing the
narrative blaming the vaccine roll out
on trump now so all the negative effects
and all that will be blamed on president
trump coming forward dr burks is coming
out and saying oh we knew the whole time
they weren't effective
they're saying this the cdc coming out
and saying the same thing there was a
the uh the cnn i don't know she was some
kind of medical something that was like
huge on masks
yeah she was like huge on now she's come
out and said that now she's come out and
said the masks uh damaged my own child
so like it's like i think people get
exhausted at some point like it goes
beyond politics it's like i'm i'm being
driven in this direction i'm being
driven in that direction cnn keeps
telling me this okay now they're
changing their mind and it's just like
this this constant just exhaustion of
the mind where the cult begins to push
you and push you and i think the people
that are waking up are just getting fed
up it's got to break down at some point
right like this is it that's someone
posted a meme and it was just like it
was janine garofalo's quote i think it
was and it said something like
if you vote the only way someone can
become a republican is that there's
something wrong with them you you can't
be an open-minded well you know thinking
individual and vote republican or
something like that
and i'm like that's not an argument
about anything like you're literally
being like the republican bad like you
didn't say that tell me why they're mad
and why you think they're wrong to be
mad but that idea i'm like if that's
what i don't know if that quote is
actually farmer it was a meme right but
this idea is laughable that people would
share it like
you've fallen for every major hoax
that's happened every single one if
there's one thing that gives me a
that gives me hope that keeps me
white-pilled and reassures me that we
are on the correct side is that we've
not fallen for all of these hoaxes maybe
once or twice we were like hey you know
what's that all about and then it comes
out like oh okay that was a hoax but the
but the left and liberals every single
hoax every time and you know you know
what it is i think a lot of it they want
to fall for they wanted jessie's
smallest story to be true it was great
but it was just so glaringly obvious the
dude was making up nonsense
anybody anybody with a brain so at what
point
do the cult leaders
lose that ability to convince
ignorant people
that these hoaxes are real at what point
do the masses just say like dude
you've lied every single time i'm over
it i have some friends on facebook from
los angeles back when i was doing a lot
of theater you called consider them
liberal i guess i don't know but we were
talking about the student loans like
where's the money coming from and some
people like i heard that it was going to
be they were just going to charge it off
to the tax to the loan companies i don't
know i don't know where it's coming from
i'm like yo look
the uh peter ducey questions the the
spokes what's her what's her title
kareem the press secretary that's her
the press secretary where's the money
coming from she dodges the question
three times in the interview i love how
nobody knows her name and so when i i
know i don't forget about jump here yeah
yeah
yeah i posted the video to my friends in
this liberal chat wherever you were
mostly and everyone's just like silent
in awe at realizing that they're
snowballing the american people they're
gonna end up charging people tax money
to pay for their own loans ahead of time
so it's like an accelerated repayment to
sallie mae like that's unconscionable
and i cannot imagine that'll pass like
if if biden's proposing it shoot it down
because that is not you don't make us
pay our own loans back early that
doesn't do anybody any justice i i don't
understand like the rejection of like
knowing how things are gonna play out
like everybody should have a house right
everybody should have a meal everybody
should have their loans forgiven but
like it doesn't work it's not pragmatic
like why are they so behold why are they
so stuck to these these uh these
fantasies i think i think they actually
want the opposite and i don't mean the
average person i think the average
liberal democrat liberal or democrat or
leftist they genuinely want people to
have these things but they're easily led
astray
if you look at capitalism uh people have
air conditioners people have
refrigerators people have clean running
water people have nicer and nicer things
now we got people sitting down with
widescreen you get a wide like 75 inch
tv for like 500 bucks it's crazy it's
crazy you go to best buy it's like
everybody's got one yeah capitalism is
making everybody very very wealthy but
you know what i think
i think a lot of the higher profile
people don't like that you will own
nothing and you will be happy they're
looking at the over consumption they
don't want everyone to live in luxury
they think that causes problems that
causes climate change so what are they
saying they want to get rid of the
airlines surprise surprise the airlines
are like spiraling out of control with
mass retirements and cancellations
they're getting what they want they
don't want regular people to be able to
do these things and here's what it boils
down to they're always ragging on you
see them ragging like jeff bezos has 130
million dollar yacht or whatever but
what they really what they what these
powerful elites these these climate
change people
and this is not an indictment or a it's
not support or opposition to the idea of
climate change
they want you all to stop having access
to vehicles to gasoline to cheap food
so that they can keep access to all
those things if you aren't allowed to
fly
then they don't have to worry about when
they fly because their contribution to
climate change is minimal you see them
all flying in private jets all the
private jets flew to europe for the
climate change conference you know what
they're really saying with what they're
they're speaking words right but the
real the real thing they're saying is
how can we take it all away from the
working class people so that we can keep
it right and i think i think
it's it's foolish to believe that
tyranny somehow just
uh disappears
out of out of planet earth or out of
society or out of mankind right it's
like it never leaves there's there's
always going to be like an entity of
tyranny somewhere on the globe wherever
you look and i think if americans
literally believe that
like if you're sitting there saying you
know that could never happen to america
like you're just you've lost your mind
like you're losing you have a losing
mindset whether you're on the left or
whether you're on the right like even if
you're someone that's like you know i
just i i love my right wing politician
and that that person is just always
gonna you know come through and save
everything it's like you you could never
let your guard down and put yourself
mentally in a position where you're just
like gonna be free sailing for the rest
of your life i mean obviously we all
want that but to think that tyranny is
just somehow just gonna you know
disappear and it's never gonna pop its
head up that's just a literally naive
you know way of thinking and and in my
opinion the the the the independent
media moderates libertarians
conservatives you know whatever this
faction is i don't like saying the right
because not everybody is
but we need something like there's this
app called thunderclap
where you would all what you would do is
you would sign up for it you'd click a
button and then it would be like do you
accept the terms and if you put yes
on the same day at the same time
everyone who agreed would tweet out it
would take take your twitter account and
tweet out the exact same message causing
them an instant trend it was called
thunderclap
the
there needs to be something like this to
help people organize the left has
institutions that help them organize and
remain organized
the right and the liberty-minded people
need something similar so that you can
very easily direct some kind of action
on things
because right now it's it's so fractured
and and just across the board and it's
difficult when you're an individualist
of course you're not going to be as
organized as a cult
yeah you know i had an interesting
interaction the other day i don't know
the name of the company but where i live
they want to install
all of this remote access to like your
thermostat into your your your air in
your house and even to the point of like
getting into your gated community like
it's all accessed through your phone
and like they approached me and they're
like hey you need you need to sign this
paper
so we can come in and have your consent
to
uh you know remote access your
thermostat to remote access uh data in
your phone to have all the data from
your phone that we can collect for this
company so that we can have that on a
daily basis like i'm sitting there
and like she's like expecting me to be
stupid she's like oh you just need to
sign it it's going to be convenient
because then you'll be able to just
access you know the gated community with
your phone the thermostat you can access
it from your home and it's like it's an
entire smart home right and i'm like
it was interesting
because i'm sitting there i'm reading
i'm reading the contract before i assign
my name on the line
and the first thing it says is you are
giving consent to the provider
and to the
uh the owner right to have remote access
to all of this technology out of your
phone and then it gets even worse and
it's like you are also giving consent
to uh give third party data that we
compile
on your phone directly it doesn't even
explain what data
and i'm sitting there reading this and
like i'm like hey
i'm not signing this i was like what
kind of data like what are you guys
talking about here you're gonna have
remote access to my thermostat i can't
say where i live but you know i'm pretty
sure people will find out where it is
but
like i'm not
that that's how they take it away and
it's like i'm saying this was the
interesting part tim because when i
started like saying that pushing back
and asking questions she came in and she
was like
yeah you know the lawyers told us that
you know if there are people that think
it's kind of weird um and they push back
they told me to just let them know and
i'm like
so if i don't sign this am i going to
get kicked out where i'm living she's
like no it's fine we just wanted to see
how many signatures we could get wow
well they already started doing this at
my apartment i came back one day and
they replaced my my key lock with one of
those touch pads so they can get in at
any time and look at the apartment and
you know i'm sure it's i already signed
it away
when i first signed but i think this
this points to the bigger cultural
phenomenon
that we've been sold on this this
society of convenience
and it's a lie it's it's a total hoax
right that if if you get something more
convenient then you're going to be
happier
and this has been happening forever
right we went from the fax machine to
the email or the
horse buggy to the car and all these
modes of communication and
transportation that are supposed to make
our lives better and more convenient
are we any less stressed are we any less
anxious are we any less busy and so
people already know and they've already
seen that we will sell our
our freedoms for convenience so why not
push it a little bit further why not put
a microchip in your body and that will
help you read your own your own body
levels better and your blood love and
they talked about this at the world
economic forum it's not just that but it
goes the other way too there's a
there's a video of a guy
in like the early 1900s and he was
around in this during the civil war a
really really old man and they asked him
at the time like
how do you feel about how technology has
changed from when you were a kid till
now because in their minds like the
automobile wow how crazy you know from
back in when the civil war and he said
oh it's the same it's all the same you
know people were happy people are happy
then people are happy now
people had to get stuff they're stressed
then they're stressed now it was things
like that and you know i think about
that we look at the technology we have
right now and act like everything's so
great but in 50 years you know maybe we
will have hover packs and flying cars
and teleportation or who knows what
we're not stressed out that we can't
teleport right now we're not sitting
here being like i can't teleport life
sucks we just wear it maybe when you're
in traffic on the freeway maybe maybe
but what i mean is
a dude people who lived in the 1700s
were satisfied with the level of
technology they had it was all they knew
and as things got better people adapted
to those better things
that's what the world economic forum
sees they see that people in 1850 they
were happy they didn't need air
conditioning sure some like there was
there was sadness people who died of
like you stubbed your toe and get an
infection and die but nowadays
people have become so spoiled and
egotistical and the example i'll give is
healthcare
there are people saying healthcare is a
human right
and my my immediate logical you know
rebuttal is if the technology doesn't
exist to cure someone is it your right
the answer is no but then if the
technology gets invented and one cure is
made because it was just invented who
has that right to it right technology so
this is this is the issue the world
economic forum sees that human beings
can be happy with things being taken
away from them and that's their goal put
everybody back down to the to the early
1900s 1800s level of technology they'll
adapt to it they'll adhere and they'll
be happy and then we'll sit atop elysium
with our flying cars yeah while they
continue to innovate move forward and
control there's a level oh of
convenience you're mentioning where like
they're replacing your locks on your
door so that they can get access like it
would be convenient if uh someone
slipped into my shower and washed my
back for me and my armpits but i'm not
into it i don't need it thanks no don't
need that level of convenience
yeah but it's my house if you look at
these excerpts from books or whatever
articles from 50 100 years ago
and they asked people what do you think
the technology is going to be like in
100 years they do talk about flying cars
and hover pads but it goes to what you
were saying that you know the elite are
going to have that the elite can have
access to that but it's not for the
masses right the masses get the
bluetooth toaster and the fridge that
talks to you it's like why do i need a
bluetooth why do i need a fridge that
talks to me but people like it and the
masses are sold on that yeah man so with
with all that uh happening let's jump to
this story from timcats.com
white house double doubles down on
biden's semi-fascism claim about maga
republicans
there you know this is this is a it's
sad it's pathetic that biden said this
that uh korean gene pierre jean-pierre
harvey brown
reaffirmed it uh
but it is kind of worrying when the
president is now starting to embrace
the extremist rhetoric it's one thing
when he said he was going to be a great
uniter and bring bill together and now
he's continually doing the exact
opposite it makes me worried about
what he wants
what the what the establishment wants
for this country
was that was that in reference to the
tweet that he put up or his his team his
handlers put up about pissing off moms
like the mega republicans have pissed
off them no he said they were
embracing semi-fascism okay so this is a
separate tweet but it's like oh here we
go yeah that's that's the thing dude
it's like it's it's the continued
gaslighting you know you almost get
exhausted talking about it it's like we
know these people are the fascists
they're the ones that are pro-lockdown
they're the ones that are you know
hailing the fbi going after their
political enemies they're the ones that
are literally calling to swat marjorie
taylor green and we know they did three
times three times and like oh there's a
trans person's life a trans person's
life is in danger like literally we know
why they're doing it because they want
her to get shot
what happened was is is that what they
claimed at her house they said the 911
call and they said it was a trans person
now it's the 911 call wow but i think
this is like a deeper issue too right
it's like this idea that your political
opponent doesn't just disagree with you
because they disagree with you and the
things that they disagree with you on
makes them an evil person it makes them
reprehensible it makes them that we
can't be part of the same country and
you saw this with with kathy hokel in
new york too recently where she was
telling her constituents that voted red
or voted for the right the republican
get on an airplane get on a bus and go
down to florida where you belong because
you're not a new yorker and so it's like
it's like this winner-take-all kind of
mindset in politics that if we win then
everybody else that voted against us is
a terrible human being and i don't want
to share a country with you right it's
not just you vote a different because
you may live in upstate new york and
you're a farmer and you have different
prerogatives and different uh you know
things that you care about it's you're
an evil person what is semi-fascism
you know i think it is i think if like
what does that even mean it means if he
came out and said fascist he'd have
nowhere to go
so he needs to be able to one-up it so
now in 2023 24 in election season he's
gonna be like they've gone to full
fascism now yeah but that was 20 that
was 2016 to 2020. yeah but now he's
talking about the regular people
it's like they're trying to find a way
to to go away from trump and then take
whatever the anger they had towards
trump and apply it to everyone well they
already did this with the um you know
the moms and the school boards right it
was like merrick garland calling these
these school moms uh you know domestic
terrorists
yeah you know i guess i could see that i
i i see the escalation there because
like 2016 to 2020 was like trump's a
fascist refused fascism
antifa calling out saying that you know
this is the second coming of adolf
hitler referring to trump but
that was like the rhetoric of the
extremists on the left like on the
ground right because i hear that i'm
like that's nothing new but i guess now
hearing it like officially from like the
top democrat
i think in the white house is is the
rhetoric goes from antifa black lives
matter these psychos on the left i think
that's a testament to who's really
behind him right now which is it's not a
surprise right very often
like this use of the term fascists is
kind of insane because what do you what
do you call fascism corporate government
collusion i mean that's like mussolini's
fascism when the state and corporations
come together for the greater
empowerment of the state we've got the
fbi is working with facebook with all
the social media companies we've got
slave labor in china where we're getting
our clothing from like it's the system
is fascist we're built on a fascist
system we're all semi-fascists because
we're participating in it
so you know but their end of story quit
blaming people for it well there are
people who oppose it then biden is
actively in it while accusing you of
doing i'd like to know what their
opposition really entails because
speaking out against it but then still
doing it is not an opposition it's it's
foe it's it's you know if anything it's
hypocritical yeah but it's only fascism
like technically to them if it's coming
directly from the government like
they're circumnavigating that by you
know even with the zuckerberg thing like
i disagree like the the they're cheering
on the feds
it's only fascism if it opposes them
and it could like literally anything you
could be a kid selling candy bars and
then be like you're dumb and they'll be
like fascists yeah i mean you've got the
fbi raiding the former president's home
unprecedented you've got coveted
lockdowns and they're still calling you
the dude who's like can i cut someone's
hair i'm a barber no you're a
fascist it's like desantis too that's
like
charlie crist is going with that
narrative desantis is a fascist well
charlie chris called him a dictator and
you see that he called him a dictator a
couple days ago and he was like
just like a dude i was lifting the
measures i was trying to let people
troubleshoot their lives trump wasn't
calling out the military during the
riots which many people thought he
should have i think he should have the
day two i thought he should have i
actually told you that day two is like
this is gonna get out of control
national guard in there right now there
are still too many people
who think they can convince fascists
that they're not fascists you know what
i mean they're like you called me a
fascist but but i'm not i swear bro the
half these people they know full well
you're not a fascist you're not going to
convince them donald trump trying to win
over the mainstream media is just
laughably dumb like he's giving them
interviews he's giving and then what do
they do every single time they lie about
him they smear him and he keeps doing it
yeah it kind of like goes backwards on
his initial like fake news
you know swipes
2015 and on but you know what's
interesting about about this claim
you know semi-fascism you know according
to the white house claim about mega
republicans i just love
how these people wrap everyone in this
title what does that mean you know the
black the blacks right the black mega
republicans the brown mega republicans
all the minorities get wrapped in one
like the it's just so mind-blowing that
these are the same people that are like
oh we're anti-racist and we're gonna
defeat white supremacy we're gonna
defeat systemic racism but you know what
let's just wrap all of you in one little
freaking box and put you in one little
fascist box you're the enemies you mega
black you're the enemy you mega brown
that's the rhetoric of these people yeah
and like i just i people need to wake up
because it's like dude stop believing
that v it's literally like an agenda
like people need to understand it is a
political tactic to prop themselves up
as the saviors of these races
people need to know that i think a large
component of it is rooted in nothing it
is it is
literally nothing
when you have a
prominent individuals
who have their roots in nothing they'll
say anything
and so they end up making making videos
where they'll say anything for the sake
of adhering to the cult for example like
on this show for instance um oh i think
it was nina turner
she tweeted out that credit scores were
created in 1989 and they to keep people
poor people poor and it should be
abolished and i said agreed i think the
credit scoring system is bs and should
be gotten rid of absolutely you want you
want to give a loan to somebody there
shouldn't be a credit scoring system
where we have no accountability to how
they how they do it i've i've had
instances where
companies will put a derogatory mark on
my credit and i can't do anything about
it screw that and they're and they're bs
she's right and she's a fringe like
she's a very lefty we've we've
criticized her heavily but i'll shout
her after being right but there are many
of these political commentators on the
left will never do that in fact my
favorite example when we did a segment
on conservatives being more attractive
than liberals because science shows it
the young turks insulted me called me
ugly and then went but he's right
what was the point of that i don't think
being concerned does it make you more
attractive it's that attractive people
tend towards conservatism because
they're happy with the status quo
because they're getting things given
exactly exactly and that was what we
were saying it's it's it's idea of
privilege because these people claimed
that like working out and being healthy
is like a symbol of white supremacy now
they're now they're upset about it that
people have privilege or whatever
what really bothers me about this is
this divide and conquer mentality of
like the the mega republicans being evil
is like it's what mao's communist
uprising did in china they had the red
class and the black class and it was
like if you were a communist in the
party you were red and if you were you
know not then you were part of this
black class and the other kids at the
school would know and they would make
fun of the kids whose parents were in
the black and so they had like the way
to get entrance into the red class which
was the okay one is you'd have to turn
someone in or return your parents this
is what they're doing it's a cult this
is it it feels like that it's a divide
and conquer and it's really low i mean
either low intelligence strategy or or
it's insidious and it's on purpose i
can't i can't figure it out i just want
to shout out one of the funniest things
i've seen in a long time was
hassan [ __ ]
getting doing a video review of a song
we released two years ago will of the
people where he was saying it was wrong
and it was like he called it awesome but
i don't know if he was saying that was
like ironic or whatever but he was
criticizing it saying it was just not
good and stuff like that
and the comments were people saying i
actually liked that song i have it in my
playlist oh no i didn't realize that was
tim poole and that's the funny thing
about it you like the song the song is
good the message is good and then you
found out it was from me and then you
got mad and didn't like it
that's a cult no they got mad and they
still liked it maybe but they have to
tell so this is the thing right
nickelback for instance a great example
of this if if look man i just got to say
the
one day someone held up a sign that said
rahm emanuel likes nickelback and then
all of a sudden nickelback became banned
non-grottos like if you like nickelback
you're not fun you're not cool you're a
loser even though they have multiple top
10 hits as i have to say not my jam but
clearly people like it if they were
number one for four weeks straight which
is kind of crazy it's like that's a feat
to perform but all these leftists are
like nickelback is dumb nickelback is
dumb because all they know how to do is
parrot each other and say what is
acceptable a good example when i was the
battle for berkeley not the battle a
battle for berkeley there were many of
them
and i was staying on the street with my
my gopro and my gimbal and i was filming
some woman walked up to me and started
talking about all of this stuff
and then i asked her a woman got knocked
down to the ground and had her head
cracked open did she deserve that and
she said well she shouldn't have been
supporting trump and i said so you think
because she supported trump it was okay
for bill's going to attack her she's
like yes and then i was like so if like
a woman was wearing skimpy clothes and
walked into a bunch of men and they
attacked her it'd be her fault and she
goes
yeah and then i was like okay then a few
minutes like she like we we leave like
she walks away we wrap up she walks back
over and she's like delete it delete it
she said things that weren't approved by
the mob i blurred her face i don't have
any interest in you know getting her
life destroyed but it was clear that
when you try to interview many of these
people they don't do it and this is
exactly why the the exact reason why the
left will not come out onto this show
but conservatives will do it all day and
night is because conservatives are
individualists who have their own ideas
and the left are in a cult and they
don't know what's approved and what's
not i feel like that even goes toward
like to what joe rogan was saying in his
endorsement of republicans
it's like i you might lean left or be
more independent but
you know these people that are going
like all or nothing it's like i might
lean that way but to call everybody a
mag or republican who you disagree with
is just evil and and i can't support
that what is mega republican anyways
these are these the people that voted
that think trump won the election and
they voted for trump well is this a new
term like in this context at least
getting away from trump's supporter no i
think mega republican just refers to
the the new right
like that's a problem that's the mtg
there are people that are like trump's
my president i love trump like those
people you know cultism in general is
pretty bad you don't really want to be
fall into a cult of any kind
but
you know just because you voted for
donald trump or you have questions about
the election doesn't make you like a
cult doesn't make you a call right right
now you have to vote for somebody if
you're going to vote right another
republicans are split between trump and
desantis
on the left they all marched in lockstep
behind joe biden and still post insane
defenses of him granted i understand the
leftists don't like joe biden but they
all made videos talking about why you
had to vote for him which is crazy joe
biden was establishment donald trump was
anti-establishment if you claim to be a
revolutionary who supported the
establishment
for what reason the argument for
if you were a leftist who want a
revolution trump was your guy he was
destroying everything wasn't he he was
going to fire the bureaucratic state and
purge the civil servants for what good
reason would you defend the
establishment unless you're lying and
you're a reactionary fascist who wants
to turn the clock the clock back to the
1950s and create racial segregation as
one example it's like it's like
so it's like their superpower though
right like they you know we split our
our support among these candidates
they hate the right or they hate trump
more than we love you know one one like
group or our ideologies or our freedoms
or like isn't that like a superpower
that they have i think they genuinely
hate black and brown people um i mean
even my run-in with katie hobbs on
saturday like i i typically don't do
content like that but it just was so
necessary because people need to
understand she's running for governor of
arizona as a democrat right she's
literally a convicted racist like two
times she discriminated against black
people so i go to this arizona put on by
the arizona democrat party her little
event where she's speaking she's
pointing the finger at republicans
republicans are this republicans or that
and here i am as a brown guy just
standing up and asking her a question
hey well what about you katie why don't
you explain to the people about you
being a convicted racist because you
literally discriminated against black
people and who are the ones that got up
in immediately literally put hands on me
and escorted me escorted me physically
out of the building they deported me
it was the woke whites the woke whites
are the ones who immediately go after me
put hands on me and i'm like are you
guys really doing this right now like
the the the the democrats of arizona are
deporting a person of color they're
deporting a latino because i'm calling
out katie hobb's racist record yeah what
did she do exactly so during her a
little administration when she was you
know in in office i think a senator i
believe
she literally
um
a black woman was working for her miss
adams and she discovered that her white
colleagues were making more money than
she was
so she came out and called it out and
asked some questions and said why
okay and apparently she went on a paid
leave or a paid vacation that was
already scheduled and during that
vacation
she was fired let go wow so she clapped
back
sued them and she won okay this is just
one of them she won i think it was like
three million dollars but it was capped
at 300k or something right
so katie hobbs is a convicted
discrimination discriminator against
black people okay so the reason why i
bring this up is like if katie hobbs was
a republican this would be headline news
everywhere if katie hobbs had an r next
to her name
i would have done the same thing same
scenario
and i would have been hailed a champion
and i probably would have been invited
on cnn to come out and talk about it
tonight
the point i'm trying to make is i i make
these points because we all get this i
know tim this is just like simple basic
stuff but i know there are people out
there that that do not even understand
how this simulation works how is it that
i can't do that as a brown man that
these people claim they champion and we
don't want to deport hispanics but the
moment i come out and i call out a
legitimate a legitimate case of racism
but because she has a d next to her name
she gets a pass and the brown guy gets
deported because they're the real racist
i just it's a point to say it's a cult
these people do not care about us they
do not care about brown people they do
not care about black people they only
care about their power and how they're
perceived in the moment and if they can
get you in the cult yep
bend the knee that's the culture they
want to build i had a guy messaging me
uh over the weekend he said that the
reason he hates me he posted a comment
is because i'm shattering consensus
reality
and i was like wow like you just come
out and admit it like you're aware that
you're in a cult and you're mad that i'm
waking people up is that it so it wasn't
that you said anything that was you know
factually wrong it was that you were
breaking what do you call it consensus
reality they you in order to keep people
trapped you have to lie keep them in the
dark and don't let them see the light
and that's why people like brian stelter
he was like don't go and watch fox news
that's propaganda fear if you went and
watched fear watch tucker carlson for
instance you might be like he's kind of
a dick but he's right like he he says
here's the thing and then you're like
let me check thing you're like oh thing
is true he kind of delivers it in a
snarky way sometimes a lot of people
like it you know he's a big show some
people might not like it but he's not
wrong he's wrong sometimes everybody is
but that's that's that's the issue they
don't want you being able to see any of
that stuff yeah i think it's the
metaphor i keep feeling is like if
there's a governor of a city that's
about to be invaded the governor tells
everyone hey everything's going to be
fine make sure everyone wakes up there's
no fear of anything all that thing you
heard about invasion is just it's just
rumors and then when the city is invaded
the people are still there they defend
the city they win as opposed to a
governor that's like hey everyone we're
going to be invaded and everyone freaks
out and flees the city then when the
city's invaded it's conquered so they
think that they're lying as justified
because it's keeping people calm and
that maybe when we transfer to this new
world order that the americans stability
will remain because we didn't panic but
you've got to see that the lying is
causing people to panic i'm sorry to
interrupt it's always fear it's always
like everything that's why everything's
a phobia
phobia is attached to everything
transphobia homophobia
if it's not that it's some kind of virus
that's going to come and kill everyone
but what about the virus no we don't
need to know it's the same thing jim
jones did
right the jonestown cult right i was
listening to this uh some some audio
books on the way in and i was just like
kind of making the parallels like this
jim jones operated through fear it was
pure fear he like in the in the
jonestown cult like every night they
would have like the white nights where
every single night he would
psychologically prepare them to die and
to suicide themselves for him every
single night like he he would come out
hey tonight's the night tonight's the
night we're gonna do he would push it
entirely and he was psychologically
engineering them through fear every
single night every single oh but no no
this was just a test until finally that
night came where they all were willing
and ready to suicide themselves because
it was literally fear
i want to accomplish that power through
fear
i want to go back to the same time i
want to go back to something
you know that you made a point and i
want to bring the story up from the new
york post abercrombie deletes ad after
tweet storm over normalizing obesity
i saw this
this image and uh you know i want to
start out by saying i'm not trying to be
mean to this woman i don't know who she
is but i want to say one thing
will the new york post not let us
actually get the image in there uh she
needs help
she needs serious help and i'm not
saying to be mean i'm not trying to be
disrespectful this woman her life is in
danger yeah her pants are being used as
a hammock for her stomach i am not
trying to be mean or disrespectful this
is no way intend to do that it's to make
a point
i'm sure she's a nice person but she is
suffering from morbid or moribund
obesity
it's it's a large a principal cause of
cancer precursor to cancer your heart
will fail you will die people are making
this into a a job they're rewarding it
and when i see this it's just one
component of what i see as
you call it cultural decay in the united
states i'm going to call it outright
societal collapse
if we normalize
morbid and more abundant obesity
in how many generations do we have one
two when our population is collapsing
and unable to sustain itself so
abercrombie i would say in in in a case
for optimism deleted the ad
but there was that famous story in l it
was in the uk i think it was where they
had this ad as beachbody ready do you
guys remember this and it was a thin
woman in a bikini and then all of these
fat activists got angry and said it was
fat phobic or shaming so they replaced
it with like a similar ad of morbidly
and more abundantly obese women
i'm just saying when i see this stuff
you talk about the cult fat phobia and
all these other phobias it is leading in
one direction and it is societal
collapse and i'm not talking about oh no
you know if if two men get married
settle collapse no i'm totally fine with
gay marriage that's that's fine actually
i think marriage is a good institution
and they're you know i'm sure the
conservatives have their arguments
against it or whatever but i don't think
that will destroy society what i think
will destroy society is when outside of
that you tolerate the targeting of
children outside of that you actually
tell people that they can be more
abundantly obese and it is marketable
and we will pay you to do it and it's
like when your society starts telling
you that
it's falling down but that's like real
compassion right like you're looking at
this woman and saying you're not living
a good quality of life i want something
better for you and i think it ties into
this this bigger idea in our society of
like tolerance right if you don't
tolerate everything then you're bigoted
or you're hateful
but it's like no i actually have my
ideas that are rooted in something
and you know british journalist douglas
murray talks about this he calls this
year zero
that today you know we think that we are
smarter and we know more than everybody
that came before us
and none of your ideas are rooted in
anything
and that's dangerous because if it's not
rooted in anything then the people that
come after you can also uproot whatever
you've just built
and so it's it's not compassionate to
have to glorify this right it's not
compassionate to let a 10 year old
decide what gender they are because we
have things that we look to our past and
say well this isn't right well we need
to fix this
but but we're being sold on this fake
idea of tolerance this this fake idea of
compassion and it's leading our society
to complete the evil it is 100 it is
evil in my opinion to go to someone
like i make the joke when i we got these
cookies they're oreo cookies
with birthday cake filling dipped in
fudge
covered in sprinkles with a sugar
printed image that says step on snack
and find out on top
and the joke is when i hand it to people
i say it's evil to do this
it is because
these things are extremely bad for you
but the reality is like
in saying that we you're it's a warning
basically like i always tell people like
dude one cookie is 130 calories in like
18 to 20 carbs so that's addictive and
it's an addictive but here you have
people who
they go to these people and they tell
them
eat a pint of ben and jerry's all to
yourself it's fine you should be you
shouldn't be ashamed of who you are
that's like giving someone poison and a
dick and
trying to addict them to something and
then like you're not helping them like
i'm sure opiates feel good we aren't
happy that doctors are over prescribing
them you're not helping someone by
getting them addicted to these drugs i
feel the same way about so much in this
in the society the reality is hard work
is a better gift this is the challenge
if your messages work hard work out and
you will feel better than ever
but people are like in the short term it
sucks it hurts
then the other people come by and say
here's a glazed donut with a double
cheeseburger a luther burger and it will
taste good right now
what they're not telling you is that you
will suffer for this curse and they're
telling you they're the good guys doing
it we want people to roll up their
sleeves and work hard and they will feel
better they will be happier they will
clear their minds
and that's and that's that's the hard
message
so telling people work hard pay back
your loans you took a loan out well all
that's like that's so mean no no no free
ride free ride
nothing good comes easy man and you know
i think it's all tied together the
tolerance the convenience right all
these people that they have amazon the
big flat screen tv
smoking pot eating their glazed donuts
like are they happy they were told that
they would be happy
but they're not they're sad they're
empty they're fat and so i mean we have
to pick out things in our society that
we need to be intolerant of right not
not in the sense that we should hate
people like i don't hate her like you
just said but we need to to decide what
is right what makes us happy what is
actually good
um but i think you know it's this scare
tactic that if you oppose anything then
you're bigoted then you're hateful right
i'm not tolerant of murderers
i'm not tolerant of of a parents drew
that that take their kids to drag shows
and we need to be we need to draw the
lines somewhere and they're erasing
every line everywhere but it's it's it's
this idea you know so i was driving in
the car and that song by taylor taylor
swift came out what came on what is it
called um you need to calm down love t
swift t swift yeah the song is
like it's a little bit about cancel
culture and the second verse is about
homophobes and transphobes and all that
stuff
and it's like it's it's
this idea
that people only criticize
another a behavior because they hate a
person
is just wrong but here's the funny thing
when i hear that and she's singing the
song and she's like you need to stop
just talking about all the reasons you
hate this person
and i'm like you know the conversations
we have here with people who are
concerned about like drag shows for
children they're not saying that it's
just because they hate someone they're
not looking at the person and being like
oh i just hate them they're saying hey
what are you doing to those kids it's
about an action and towards kids for the
most part they're they're i i've uh i
was at an event in the uk and there's a
drag queen on stage or whatever one
going after kids nobody cared i've been
at trump events where there have been
transgender trump supporters nobody
cared they don't hate them they hate the
actions when you target and do like a
child and do something corrupt
in this instance with abercrombie and
fitch it's just a long line and a big
story about getting people to gorge
themselves until they're in serious
jeopardy that is not compassion well
this goes back to what i was saying is
these people hate you
right like if i'm sitting here
telling you
it's okay to be unhealthy
keep being unhealthy
see how that goes for you you should be
as unhealthy as physically possible
that's not a statement of care that's a
statement of hate that's the real hate
right if i come out and say you know
what it's fine mutilate the genitals of
your children that is going to go so
well for them that is going to make them
so happy in the future even though they
have no idea why they're doing what
they're doing keep doing that it's going
to go so well in the future it's a
statement of hate that means you hate
somebody but but and maybe they hate you
maybe they they uh
they want there to be less people but
when i look at a lot of this i look at a
message that says
in the what is the end result of all of
the things they're saying from you know
we're talking about the morbid obesity
being normalized to the um you know just
the abortion of the point of birth
the end result of this whether it's
intentional or not will be less people
pain and suffering and death
and then people being unable to
reproduce and then people not having
kids
so i look at that and i'm like i'm not
saying anyone who's pushing for fat
acceptance or whatever is trying to
reduce population i'm saying the end
result will be regardless of what you
want less people now china's not doing
this in fact they're doing the opposite
they're not letting these messages
persist on tick tock in china but in the
u.s they are so what's going to happen
the u.s is crumbling china is also
having their own economic problems but
in the social ways they're rejecting it
they're doing these ads like to promote
masculinity and stuff like that
meanwhile they're using their app in the
us to push wokeness
uh what app exactly tick-tock tick-tock
that's bite dance a chinese company and
spying on people you talk about
compassion i'm thinking about like
raising a kid and a kid that like maybe
the kid goes and steals something from
the store and comes home what's the
compassionate thing to do it's okay
don't worry about it i love you anyway
that's not i don't think that's
compassion it's that kid you lose your
privileges you return that you apologize
you cry about it you feel horrible about
it you you feel you know
you feel humiliated then you come home
and you you lose electricity in your
bedroom now we're shutting off the
breaker you're in your room
you cannot stay over your friend's house
on the weekends you have to be home at 5
p.m every day until for three months
like that's maybe hardcore but that will
teach the kid don't steal do not destroy
society that i think is compassion as
horrible and as hard as it is to do that
to a kid like you're guiding these wild
animals like what you don't you know is
it compassionate to shear the sheep yet
we do it anyway i don't know actually it
is the sheep like it yeah they do well
i'll tell you here i'm screaming when
their legs are tied up it's another
another question well you know there's
some things we do to farm animals they
don't like yeah that's what's
insemination i'll make like the the
religious
the religious analogy or the christian
analogy of you know when god punishes
you or when you sin
um and drew i don't know about you but
like you know we have a set of rules
right we have a set of ideologies that
that we are rooted in and you may
disagree with the ideology with religion
but when we sin we're told you have to
atone for these sins you have to confess
and don't you always feel great when you
confess and you say i did this wrong let
me let me try to have some forgiveness
and that's like coming from god right
and it's the same thing with kids
that you have somebody over you telling
you this is right and this is wrong and
that's why i think maybe some of these
people hate you hate us but i don't
think everybody does i think it really
is
rooted in a lack of ideas right they
don't have roots in anything and it's
running amok i mean we're seeing it in
real time well because they've been
convinced that liberalism right they've
been convinced that liberalism means
just all hands are off
you can't have a functioning society
without any kind of rule of law because
then you run into stuff like this if
we're just void
of rule of law in a society then
the
the the the
the sexualizing of kids is okay in a
society like that because you can who
the hell are you to say anything you're
a fascist you're telling me that i can't
touch your kid you're a fascist that's
where these people's minds are there has
to be some kind of moral code in society
or as the society cannot function there
is no more like the moral code has been
destroyed and you know with with the
with the drag kid stuff you know people
say well their parents they can decide
what they want their kid to do
but why is it not okay for a parent to
give their bottle to give their kid a
bottle of jack and say well it's my kid
i can allow him to drink well they say
that's harmful to them it's physically
harmful and you cannot do that that's a
failure societal standard that we've set
it's culture and values why are we not
allowed to set societal standards when
it comes to morality right like 50 years
ago if you taught the communist
manifesto
in school you'd probably get fired as a
teacher
but now you can teach kids about
sexuality you know they have these
transition closets
why can't why are we not like where is
it going why is there no structure at
all there is a rejection of that there's
been a rejection of that but there is a
very deep seated cult that is trying
very very hard to maintain these things
like wokeness in this country
is not
that prominent but they are influential
because they've seated themselves in our
institutions
so what's happening now is we i hear it
in every facet there are there's police
officers who are like oh i don't want to
say too much because i lose my job there
are fbi agents who are like if i speak i
lose my job and then what happens the
cult and the establishment get to do
whatever they want because the people
who know what's going on are too scared
to speak up and it's really frustrating
and that is a major black pill now when
you look at at least the elections over
the past you know few months major white
pill when you take a look at abercrombie
pulling that ad i'd say it's a white
pill i'm feeling rather optimistic but
it is really frustrating every day when
it's just like
people are are too scared to actually
just say nah yeah after 2001 and 9 11 um
the patriot act got signed and i feel
like it bred a a generation of
psychopaths no offense if you were
raised in this situation you just don't
know that what you you that your lack of
understanding about the danger of the
patriot act is if you don't realize that
the patriot act is a complete subversion
of everything that the united states
constitution was meant to stand for then
you've been you've fallen for this lack
of morality and then i went through a
phase where i was like well if we're
doing evil around the world if we're
invading and conquering iraq for weapons
of mass destruction that didn't actually
exist then how can i criticize the
chinese government for having people in
camps i don't have a moral authority to
do that so i actually went through a
phase where i was like i can't be a
moral arbiter anymore because the united
states is doing such evil things but i
realize like just because the united
states act is evil i think it's an evil
act uh doesn't mean that we can't stand
up for what's right when we know it's
right or if we believe it's right we
still have an opportunity and
we have a responsibility to do if we
don't do it who's no one will not only
should you but you have to well i think
i think this this is like the kyle
rittenhouse situation right people are
coming out you know the newsweek letters
or the newsweek articles with richie
coming out and saying that oh he's not a
hero that's fine he could have his
opinion that that's cool right but in
that situation i think that was the
perfect example of this because you had
2020 on full lockdowns
you had these riots that were made
mainstream and they were normalized
kenosha was on fire for three days
straight but mostly peaceful right but
mostly peaceful and the writers were the
ones that brought guns first on night
one i was there right look
let me pull this story let me but this
is the this yeah okay let me pull this
story and get some context into uh we
have this from newsweek it's from richie
mcginnis he's a good friend of the show
says i was in kenosha two years ago kyle
rittenhouse is not a hero there's a lot
to go through in his op-ed to understand
his position
he says before the shooting started 11
36 p.m on august 25th 2020 i ran into
cal rittenhouse in front of a gas
station and interviewed him for several
minutes he was a 17 year old kid with a
semi-automatic rifle and he was playing
cops surrounded by people who didn't
want him there rittenhouse didn't see it
that way quote so people are getting
injured and our job is to protect this
business and part of my job is also to
help people
he told me for the third night in a row
half of downtown kenosha was a blaze
when there's somebody hurt i'm running
into harm's way thirteen minutes later
written how standing feet from me would
kill one man a few minutes after that
he'd kill another then he'd maim a third
interesting thing is
uh well actually you know
unless we have to like read the whole
piece i'm not gonna do it richie
mentions that he was he remained neutral
kept his opinion to himself so that he
could be a witness on the stand and he
and he pushed back when you know that
the defen when the when the prosecutors
tried claiming you know that written
house wasn't being threatened he was
like you know rosenbaum said f you and
then reached for the gun things like
that
but he richie
drew you were there and you read this
article so like you should give your
position and give yourself i was in the
trial too like i'm not going to
attack richie here right richie can have
his own opinion that's fine that's cool
but i was there too okay i saw the same
exact things i watched joseph rosenbaum
get shot i was right behind richie when
he put rosenbaum in the back of the
ambulance all that same trauma they were
hitting him i witnessed two yes i
witnessed it too all that same trauma
but
the real question here is
is kyle rittenhouse really the villain
and this goes back to the point i was
trying to make is what happens when law
and order pulls back
are you left to defend yourself
are you left to defend your own
community because that's what happened
in kenosha
i wasn't there on night two
and i wasn't just there on night three i
showed up night one i blew up that story
that went worldwide to the kenosha riot
that was my footage so when i speak on
this no one can talk about kenosha
without talking about the context of
kenosha right jacob blake got himself
shot they started throwing bricks at
police officers heads i showed up on the
scene that night they were burning down
kenosha period it was not a protest
there were no protesters and the rioters
are the ones that showed up with guns
and were pointing them at police
officers for three consecutive nights
they did this they burnt down multiple
car dealerships okay they were burning
committing arson looting the whole nine
yards the police were being told to
stand down this is why the community in
the area if you guys remember they were
boarding up the windows and they were
writing things like hey elderly people
live here the handicapped live here you
want to know why because that little
community thought they were going to die
because of these rioters all right there
was an old man who got bashed over that
with a rock exactly
when you talk about why kyle rittenhouse
was in kenosha this you have to talk
about this stage that led to people
showing up oh banging on the table wait
so oh yeah but i'm sorry this isn't my
show you're feeling this um but but it
goes through the microphone yeah you
have to talk about what why was he even
in kenosha right and they always say oh
you see he crossed state lines he caught
well antifa on night two after the first
night of rioting were literally
mobilizing from portland and seattle to
cross state lines multiple rights
multiple multiple i want to so i want to
point something out here this gets to
the heart of the argument this is an
article from richie and he brings up
something interesting he says protesters
kept trying to climb into the suv this
is after rosenbaum got shot i couldn't
see who was punching me but the blows
kept coming i kicked someone trying
furiously crazily to grab onto the rear
bumper as we raced to the hospital when
we finally got there we stopped at the
bottom of a ramp leading to the er i
tried not to cry as we waited for the
metal security door to open it's gonna
be okay bro i told rosenbaum we're gonna
have a beer after this and laugh about
it it was hard to hear my voice over the
sounds of rosenbaum struggling to
breathe and gargling blood instead as we
pulled into the hospital i watched gays
i watched gage gross crates limp through
its doors a police officer held his
butchered arm it was a mangled mass of
flesh and bone not fully amputated but
not quite an arm i didn't know the time
but anthony hoover was lying dead in the
pavement just outside the hospital
so here's what here's what i see here
i think richie is affected emotionally
by this yeah and i was just gonna say
that and from my perspective having been
someone who was not there but who
interviewed all of you guys and on more
than one occasion i hear a story and
i've seen footage and i've heard a trial
and i see a man rosenbaum who threatened
to kill a 17 year old kid more than once
and then tried to make good on that by
reaching for the weapon the moment he
reached for that weapon he created the
threat of deadly force against kyle
because if he got control of that of
that muzzle
and then started fighting kyle who knows
what happened a gunshot went off behind
kyle
now all he knows is a guy is chasing me
who threaten to kill me someone's
shooting and i don't know where and he
turns around and what does he get
rosenbob tries to grab the gun
richie's affected by that saying we're
going to have beers together i get it
i've i've seen some horrifying stuff not
nearly that level but i've seen people
die i've seen people be seriously
injured and i can certainly understand
why richie was looking at that and like
on the verge of tears be like we're
gonna grab beers bro
from an outside perspective looking at
this from a mathematical a logical
standpoint that makes no sense this is a
guy who was trying to who's threatening
to kill someone and attacked them why
you would want to get beers at them as
if they're the victim when they're the
aggressor
i'm not happy that this happened to him
i'm not happy that kyle was there i
think even kyle said he probably
wouldn't have gone you know in hindsight
or something like that i'm not happy
that somebody lost their life but i'm
not going to sit here and be like i'm
going to shed a tear over the guy who
instigated violence threatening to kill
somebody
like we we have to recognize violence is
wrong it sucks it's bad and then we have
to recognize rosenbaum initiated it he
was the one who was doing the bad and we
were lucky that kyle was able to defend
himself it was unfortunate for everybody
that it played out this way well joseph
rosenbaum said shoot me n-word multiple
times and was requesting to get shot so
he got his death wish he got what he
wanted because he was there committing
crimes literally five minutes before
that took place joseph rosenbaum not
only requested to be shot okay but he
was committing arson right before they
even got to that car dealership where
that all took place so people understand
it's like kyle was administering
uh first aid on both sides he even
admitted that under oath in the trial as
well so like it's like
you have to understand the the i always
make this point
these were not good people these were
not good people these people were a
threat to the community they always will
be they always have been because they
were rioting and committing mass
violence for consecutive nights joseph
rosenbaum was not a good guy and the guy
was asking to be shot saying the n-word
at a so-called blm protest i don't feel
sorry for that no one cared nobody
nobody cared that he was doing it to
your point drew i mean i think maybe a
better title of the article would be you
know kyle rittenhouse isn't a hero but
they are not victims either um and the
part of the article that i thought was
really interesting and poses a lot of
good questions was later on when when
richie talks about
kyle rittenhouse gaining national fame
right and being put up on stages and
inhaled as a hero
you know like you said drew the police
were told to stand down should there be
some sort of community action where
people do go out and protect their
businesses protect their homes should it
be an 18 year old with an ar-15
you know with the police standing down i
don't know right if there's no law in
order if there's no police presence then
is it in the hands of the citizens to
take action should an 18 year old go out
there some people would say yes then 18
year olds should arm up and go out and
protect their communities it's an
interesting question and i don't have
the answer to it i think destroying
someone's home is one of the worst
crimes you could ever commit killing
someone is probably the worst just
breaking someone's body destroying
someone's body probably the worst
destroying someone's home
is probably the next worst crime
absolutely
death like death penalty kind of stuff
like if someone goes to a city and burns
the city down that's you've essentially
destroyed 100 million people like 10
million people i'm over here all
anti-death penalty and ian's like death
penalty for ryan why not let people
destroy people's homes i mean this goes
back 100 000 years of
torching villages and things that's like
the worst thing if you're killing people
and even if you're just destroying their
homes and sending them off in a no man's
land like that's also horrific to do to
a human so i think that the problem i'm
amanda death penalty and i think it's
because the state can never definitively
prove
that you know they have the right person
there's a risk there of giving them that
authority but the idea of defending
yourself from someone trying to burn
down your own now that's a more
interesting question
i'm fairly certain that if you are in
your house
almost every state and someone is trying
to set fire to it you they are trying to
use lethal force against you and that
would that would justify the use of
lethal force in kind west virginia
especially if you're in west virginia
and someone comes with a molotov
cocktail to throw at your house and
they're about to throw it you are
justified in using lethal force to
defend yourself a lot of states have
codified that destroying someone's home
is one of the worst things you can do
and that you can shoot on site if they
step onto your property a lot of states
have those gun rights some states maybe
are a little more lenient well the
article always also attacked turning
point usa
for you know bringing kyle on stage and
you know we we really wanted to
have like a celebration for him that's
what that was and it's like
that's that's okay you know this is this
is kind of like this falls under the
category of the new right right it's
like where no one's trying to make him a
celebrity it's like
we we had a w
okay we got a w with that
because not only did he defend himself
not only did what he do what he did was
right to defend himself in that moment
in the context of everything happening
but even the trial itself with all the
defamation saying he shot black people
president joe biden coming out saying
he's the pope literally the poster boy
of white supremacy okay the deep state
and these powers went after him hard
pure defamation okay that same playbook
that gets put on everybody
kyle won
kyle won because god was on his side and
he was acting in truth and righteousness
the the point i'm trying to make is
the reason why
we wanted to celebrate that is because
we have to at this point we have to how
many l's like aren't people sick of just
continually taking l's to these people
continually letting the deep state win
continually letting them just go after
anyone that's a freedom lover or a
patriot it's like every single time they
get what they want we finally had hope
where honestly i i thought kyle was
probably gonna be put away yeah the way
things were going the way things always
go these people always win they always
win they always get a w so so you i'm
sorry that we decided to celebrate our w
for once in a while because
righteousness won and justice won when
kyle was vindicated because what he did
was not wrong we are going to celebrate
that american america is going to
celebrate that because it was the little
guy versus big brother that's what that
trial was and the little guy won america
won justice won and we will celebrate
that and we will not be apologetic the
the the the culture war right
struggles to organize properly
consistently it's stuff like that
because someone comes out and criticizes
like oh oh
far be it from us that we celebrate
something like that because we have to
look all good no no those days are over
look how's look how long it took joe
rogan to be like okay maybe he should
vote republican exactly i mean for all
the thing that that joe's talked about
that he's criticized he still maintained
that you know he's a liberal or whatever
we've not heard it until recently he's
like okay maybe you should vote
republican well i think
if you look back at everything joe told
me you know before uh or not before the
election but i mean even even still
before the election if you look at the
things he was talking about during the
pandemic you'd think you'd have come out
sooner and been like guys you you maybe
should vote republican like is the is
the issue with joe
uh for joe that
he he only just realized the mistakes
were made right so he's talking to aaron
rodgers and he says mistakes were
seriously made during the pandemic did
joe not know that during the pandemic
that he wouldn't come out hard and be
like guys these lockdowns are wrong you
need to vote out these people who are
doing it and it is the democrats
overwhelmingly who are doing it he
didn't say that it's now he's saying and
he's saying it with a laugh and so i
look at that
and then i look at like
there's there's limited organizational
power but we're working really hard
parallel economy i'm i've i've never
been happier right parallel economy dan
banzino founded its financial
transactions censorship resistant the
cultural stuff the daily wire is doing
they're they're making movies they you
know they brought gina carano on they've
got more projects in the works what is a
woman with an amazing documentary
we've got us we rumble everything rumble
is doing
but that's the big challenge right now
the component that you have to compete
with these institutions the media
apparatus is microscopic it's it's it's
tiny and so everything has to be done
across the board to build out these
industries
to build out a space that has money
so that people can be hired so that
people can be like you know if someone
gets fired from their job for speaking
out there's a place for them to go if
you know i'll tell you this taylor
silverman the female skateboarder we
hired her and i'm excited because we're
going to have her lead our skate
projects
she was one of the first in the
skateboarding industry to come out and
be like hey this is not okay that
biological males are competing against
us how am i supposed to make a living
competing when i'm at this disadvantage
for these reasons and they attacked her
relentlessly and so i responded with
we're gonna do our best to make sure
that you're not left left hanging
because you decided to do what was right
too many people are like if i stand up
no one has my back
how can that be how can we we cannot
accept that the daily wire brought on
gina carano when they tried destroying
her career the daily wire has your back
they can't carry everyone
we've we've hired and worked with a few
people in similar situations
you know pete parado when the offspring
fired him i thought we got lucky pizza
he's such an amazing guy and he's such a
you know he's been in all these
different bands we're lucky and taylor
silverman i can't look at that and then
be like we're going to ignore you when
you do the right thing no we gotta we
gotta
make sure we're helping people in this
regard otherwise what happens is kyle
goes to jail yeah if if there was no
support for him if people didn't come
out and and now you know and i'll say
this when richie was criticizing turning
point usa i'm glad turning point brought
him out i'm glad they clap and cheer for
him this dude's not gonna have a normal
job ever again what is kyle right now
supposed to do with his life after being
attacked and lied about to this degree
you think he can apply to be a theater
at an amc they're going to be like no
way we're not going to hire you so he
needs to be able to live somehow and
them bringing him up and saying talk to
us is one way to help make that happen i
see we're not about it
it was not about like because you always
see you see this from from from the left
always oh the the new star of the far
right kyle written it's like it's it's
it's not that that's not th this is this
is literally what tim just said
it's coming alongside someone
that literally almost got obliterated
literally obliterated
okay
physically possibly god knows what
rosenbaum was going to do if he got a
hold of his gun and took it probably
would have right okay so this is this is
coming alongside of of a kid who almost
lost his life in many ways and showing
him support
showing him support that that's what
it's about okay hit like just to give
you guys some some some some background
stuff okay
kyle wants a normal life
he'll never have a normal life
he he didn't ask for this
he he just simply wants to live as
normal as he possibly can
okay like whenever i talk to him he's
just you know just like a normal teenage
young man growing up and right now
we we don't want that we we don't want
some some huge you know famous career
for this guy we we just came alongside
of him because we saw someone that
literally almost got obliterated and
destroyed by the deep state so we
decided to show him support i know
charlie kirk agrees with that i know
everyone that was on that stage agrees
with that because we saw exactly what
happened to him and that's what we
wanted and also his family his mom
at the time devastated imagine being a
mother seeing your child like literally
being put in that kind of position to
lose his life entirely almost i mean he
did the right thing
he did the right thing but so we decided
to come alongside and show them like hey
you're not alone they want you to feel
like you're alone they want every single
person watching this to feel like
they're alone and we're not going to do
that anymore
i want to jump to this next story from
timcast.com
senator lindsey graham says there will
be riots in the streets if trump is
indicted
senator lindsey graham was has warned
there'll be riots in the street if trump
is indicted the republican south
carolina senator made the remarks during
an appearance on fox news sunday night
in america over the weekend echoing
trump's recent claim that america is now
a lawless country graham said there is
no law when it comes to taking down the
former president
quote
most republicans including what do you
say including me as a typo in there
timcast.com believe when it comes to
trump there is no law it's all about
getting him and i'll say this if there
is a prosecution of donald trump for
mishandling classified information and
the after the clinton debacle there will
be riots in the streets
i completely disagree
i i 100 disagree the right doesn't riot
no we would never i mean there's been a
few instances i mean january 6 for
instance was pretty bad but it's like
they just don't
uh i i remember i was at trump tower and
they're people protesting it and there
was a guy who was you know asking
questions about what's going on and they
said he and then he was like well i'm a
trump supporter but you know i don't
know and then i was like why don't you
guys come out and like voice your
support oh no no i i could i couldn't do
that i couldn't do that well there you
go the end result of refusing to speak
your mind is being obliterated from
culture and from mainstream society the
your your inability to stand up and
support the things you like or
speak out in support of
anything related to your values will be
the end of your values
yeah well they know this right like i
mean that way i think that was a big
part in why joe biden won
is that people didn't want riots again i
heard that from many of my friends many
of my liberal friends they were like
yeah i actually don't agree with what a
lot of joe says i actually like trump's
fiscal policy or i like trump for
whatever reason but i don't want riots i
don't want my city to burn down you know
they lived in chicago or they lived in
florida they lived in
these different cities around the
country people just didn't want the
riots they were fed up with it and i
think the the media knowing this the
government people knowing this
is even maybe part in you know why they
why they rate it as home or why they
take this this massive action against
the president because they know they'll
get away with it
i'm so disappointed that he didn't sit
in the national guard tonight too man
i'll talk about it over and over again
when it comes up but like what a failure
of leadership to allow those riots to
absolutely
i'm not a big fan of lindsey graham i
don't like his alcoholism i think he's
an alcohol personally i think he's an
alcoholic when i look in his eyes
blessings
but uh well okay personal feelings aside
lindsay i don't know if you're an
alcoholic or if you struggle with
alcohol as i'm sorry i hope you can
overcome that but uh you know you say if
this happens there will be riots that's
not a form of incitement but it kind of
sounds like you're telling people to go
riot if it happens so watch your tone
you know secondly he's not wrong about
what he's saying about the the biden
crap so look look the daily wire
recently hired a disney executive and
people started going ragging on him for
it and i'm just like
the ceo of this company goes to church
on sunday guys the disney guy now works
for him
why are you why are you ragging on the
daily wire over this why are people
saying you better explain this yeah it's
called winning it's called taking over
the industry and taking over the culture
that's that's that's a problem i think
you know
purity tests
it is what it is but the left is so
obedient to their cult they have a major
advantage over the culture war right and
that the cultural war right will will
bicker the left will devour each other
but the individualists on the right are
more defined and willing to just say i
think what's happening is this left idea
this cultism is like a communist cultism
kind of thing and there's so much of the
world as communist in china and in at
least a lot of the russian holdover
states have communist threads throughout
whether or not they're overtly communist
so it's for the first time in human
history is bleeding through the internet
into american culture like we didn't
have the internet before it wasn't so
pervasive and permeable and so we're
seeing this insane
bubble of communist behavior it's crazy
it's not american it's not normal in the
united states
they thought the fbi was went after this
for like 60 years or something
50 years they were trying to stop the
communist overthrow i don't know it
turns out
communist because it's like it's more
than just that like the chinese culture
the ccp it's not real communism it's
like an evolution a new form of
technocratic you know oversight that's
not just but there are communist aspects
to it i think i think
the the solution to a lot of this stuff
is
ignore the tribes
i think the left is the cultier side but
the right has their issues sure but it's
the exception not the rule i think the
issue is just compete in the space
fund and grow and and assert yourself in
these spaces which is what we've been
trying to do it's why we we're we're not
launching overtly political stuff so
we're not we're not launching stuff to
try and pander to trump supporters or
liberals or whatever we're trying to
make things that'll be entertaining
enough for regular people
well i think you know this is something
that the left gets really right and
they're really good at is they have
their allies and they clearly define
their enemies and they let you know
people in the democratic party they'll
slip up they'll make a mistake but they
won't banish them right and the right
will keep thinking that they're going to
win brownie points for taking the high
road right this staffer says something
that's a little bit uncouth and then
they banish them they say well we're not
racist well we're not sexist it's like
they're already calling you that you're
not going to win brownie points for
taking the high road and again this is
what the left does really well it's what
i said earlier that's their superpower
their cult mentality is their superpower
is they can mess up they can do actually
racist things like katie hobb but do
they bring that up
did they call it her racism no because
they know that katie hobbs is her or
their ally
they will they will help her to get
through that and they they don't care
because they have their allies and they
have their enemies and the right needs
to get this through their heads or
they're going to continue losing yeah
it's not a time for people to sit still
and just take whatever you the high road
to turn the other cheek to look the
other way is not the time to do that
it's the time to create stuff to create
phenomenal addictive art that is so good
we're working on a video game
you know i don't know it's really hard
work andrew our game game designer is
doing an incredible job it's real fun
seamus is doing the animations and stuff
and uh this is not i guess
we haven't released a lot of information
about the game we've shown like clips of
it and stuff
man it's uh it's it's it's relatively
political but it's not the game itself
is just a video game we're going to be
uh able to play as you tim with little
uh customizable different color beanies
no but we like i think ian's gonna be in
it actually gotta pay 99 cents to get
the skin no i don't know about dlc
actually
i think you're gonna end up being like a
special character or something
like you sell rocks or something oh
that's a good idea i'll be the merchant
hey hey man yeah something the left also
does really well they're they're the
creatives they're making movies they're
making the art but they're losing it
and now is the opportunity that's why
it's like well thanks to people like you
right putting out your your songs and
you know driving traffic and like you
said rejecting the mainstream culture
rejecting the the mainstream media this
it is great it has been one of the most
stressful things ever doing all this
work to launch music more so than like
i've been playing music since since i
was like seven but i didn't expect any
of this stuff to start happening like a
million views i was just like uh okay
like we left the show on friday like oh
you're number one in alt rock on itunes
and i was like holy crap
and then the the these are the attacks
we started getting have been unrelenting
you know i'm going to stop using the
term attack when it comes to verbal crap
well okay the the the uh what's the
what's the word we're looking for then
complaints it's not they're not
legitimate complaint just why won't you
call it an attack because it's it's
softening the term attack and then
making street violence less uh
threatened i don't i don't think so look
the goal is to inflict it's it's
harassment i guess if the goal is to
inflict emotional harm but what i see
here is
you know we we launched pop culture
crisis it's it's it's growing really
really well for a show that's only you
know like half a year old 40 000 subs
getting thousands of views in there in
their episodes
uh they that brett and mary are do an
amazing job and it's talking about pop
culture it's not political and that's
the point it's like we want to just meet
people where they are and produce
content for them and then create a
sphere of influence
no hate
no one came after us over this tell from
the inverted world we got actually some
you know positive it's true crime but
then we put out a song that just took
off like crazy and all of a sudden we
have all of these left pundits just
attacking us relentlessly and i think
it's because this is
this is the move to make
the left took the arts over they use the
arts to influence children they want the
kids to grow up to be like them
controlling movies controlling
superheroes controlling tv shows you
can't turn on a show without getting
some woke garbage message now and that's
what they're trying to instill in your
kids if they can't get them in the
schools they're gonna get them on the
tvs and then parents who don't know
about her put their ipad in front of
their kids and the kids now just
listening to all the stuff so what
happens when you get a daily wire
producing movies
daily wire bought hyperions which was
just the hollywood movie
and they got really angry there was that
viral threat this is exactly the point
where they were like i watched this
movie and then i realized it was a daily
wire movie and i was like oh no what was
i promoting and i deleted it remember
that what were they shouting out
i forget but i remember this lady wrote
this ridiculous article about how she
actually enjoyed a daily wire movie and
she was really regretful because she had
tweeted positive fights
so they tweeted that they watched run
hide fight and it was really good and
they told people to watch it and then
people were like that's the daily wire
oh no oh i'm so sorry ben shapiro walked
into our podcast conference i tell you
this
they're not scared of you doing a show
and being like politics politics because
they know how to control you they know
how to say you're a fascist and then
scare people away from talking to you
but when you make a movie that's really
good that they like
oh no
now you're gonna start influencing
people now you're gonna start winning
friends and influencing people and
that's how they lose the culture war
it's remarkable to me that the right is
so resistant in many ways not everybody
to making culture in order to win a
culture war andrew breitbart said this
what was what was this now like 14 years
ago that that politics is downstream
from culture
every person on the right should be
focused on art politics of course you
know tom mcdonald is probably one of the
greatest musicians of our generation
because he's he's hitting powerful
messages he's he's speaking to tens of
millions of people and boy are they
pissed about it
this is what really grinds their gears
and freaks them out this is what this is
what wins not writing when you're
violent they know how to control you
they know that normal people get scared
of the violence they can show that on tv
screens all year and blame donald trump
for it but you know they can't do
anything about a song called fjb hitting
number one a song called fake woke
hitting number one the daily wire
putting out eight political movies that
people enjoy that is freaking them out
these people are pathetic dude like
they're literally pathetic i mean i
think they think
that they're strong-minded i think they
think that they have
some serious
rooted values
but in reality it's like you you are so
weak minded that you have no idea i mean
the bible makes it clear that you know
the fear of man is a snare and what that
means is you live your life afraid of
the opinions of people of what people
think about you or what people are
saying about you oh the mob over there
is going to think i look like this if i
listen to tim poole i actually like this
song i'm not actually going to stop
listening to tim poole because i found
out that he's an alt-right whatever i'm
just gonna do it in secret like
imagine being so pathetic so pathetic
that you can't be yourself you can't be
yourself out in the open you can
actually like what you actually like
because it's so politically polarized
imag imagine being so pathetic that you
cannot stand your ground and just be
yourself
you're an npc you're a robot you're
controlled you're controlled by the mob
you don't have an opinion for yourself
you're told what to believe you're told
what to believe by pressure and through
fear you may not even really believe it
you may not even really believe it but
you just know that oh someone on tick
tock believed it and they got cancelled
i don't ever want to be that case
people like that are pathetic and
they're losers well this is the thing
like what we're saying about nickelback
it's like dude you can rag on nickelback
all day and all day and night fine
whatever but like to deny
objectively they scored a four week
streak at number one spot like that
means people like that stuff you don't
have to like it that's fine but to act
like they they're they're not
objectively successful is just weird
cult-like behavior it is a form of
losing too like you called people losers
but it's like they lose their
opportunity to be themselves which is
the most elevating and freeing
experience on earth if you have a chance
as a human to speak openly about what
you believe
and
yeah these i mean these people do need
to be prayed for they are npcs what you
were saying is exactly right drew but
that revelation
is so powerful because i think you know
it's like if they're already calling me
racist for just my beliefs that aren't
controversial if they're already calling
me sexist
then then i'm just gonna go pedal to the
metal and go full throttle and take it
back in any way i can
um because they're like you said they're
npcs they're they're controlled by fear
and when you break that simulation
amazing things so you give people
bravery yeah absolutely
absolutely yeah these people are
destroying everything i mean like i mean
you look at she have you seen watch have
you watched e-hulk yep right it's it's
just this attack on men right
it needs to be
combated with men coming out and just
attacking it as a response right because
when when you let this agenda come out
and everyone gets de-masculine eyes
everyone gets feminized and and oh
everything's toxic because you're
masculine no be more masculine come out
i'd be aggressive yes yes yes but look
at eric july look at rip a verse yeah
how much did he make uh i think it was
like over three million three million
the ripaverse the rip of verse yeah and
what what paypal froze his money this is
the scariest thing to the cult
successful culture building
they they lose their minds over it they
have to reject it they have to attack it
and what do you how do they they can't
stop it they can't and and that's i
think you know when when she-hulk comes
out and it's and it's it's hilariously
bad garbage or whatever it's like the
lowest rated show that marvel's done yet
it's just it's cringy i give it like a c
minus i i i watch it there's some funny
bits in it but it is
not
it is what it is and if people like it
i'm fine with them liking it miss marvel
was way worse in my opinion that was
like a magic school bus show a psa on
partition in pakistan or whatever
if you don't like it let me ask you
something when you don't like
here we go here we go drew name a song
you don't like
um
friday friday rebecca black okay that
song was from
12 years 12 years ago i think is there a
song from this week that you don't like
that's like in the news
i don't even i don't know what's out
right now exactly because you don't
focus on things you don't like you focus
on the things you do like so for these
people to come out and start attacking
and criticizing the daily wire the stuff
we're doing or or you know anybody else
that's when you know you're having an
impact threatened exactly they the real
threat it's not that people on in
cultists can't stop the the art the
phenomenal art that's appearing it's
that they don't want to that's the real
threat in their minds like a cognitive
business like i like this i don't want
to stop this i was told that i'm not i'm
supposed to fear it but it's good and i
feel better and that's like this coming
to terms with yourself or your a you
know
that's it's a phenomenal it's a great
thing to witness i i think the response
to she-hulk should be what eric jolie is
doing make like daley wire should be
working on adaptations of his stuff
they should be like okay how do we turn
this into a big show because clearly the
audience wants it there's a market
opportunity and that's how you win a
culture war by making culture the i'm so
i mean look dude hearing that dude made
over three million dollars
oh it's a price it's a breath of fresh
air the more the more people are start
start working on this stuff the more
people start producing and developing
culture that's
look the elections are great but but
politics is downstream from culture you
get a law in the books that your culture
is unwilling to enforce the law is
meaningless even john roberts didn't
want to overturn roe v wade because of
where the culture was at
but then you end up with you know these
three these several other justices these
four other justices and then it becomes
well you got no choice now that's donald
trump getting them in but look at what
happens when you don't have the culture
they demonize trump and they go after
him relentlessly you you need if every
celebrity was was was more like we have
to support america otherwise we'll lose
our jobs this country would be doing
well instead they're like you have to
hate america otherwise we lose our jobs
that is an inverse economic incentive
that is destroying this country well
like that's the dangerous thing about
censorship is that if you censor
something enough it's not going to solve
any problems it's just going to make
that thing come back
with a vengeance it's going to swing
back even harder
and i think that was you know trump's
whole ethos right that they were just
suppressing the right to spread and then
he came back with this with this you
know he came back intensely and i think
it's the same thing with masculinity if
you suppress masculinity enough it's
going to come back even harder you know
you see that with andrew tate and
regardless of all the things he says
it's like they're censoring masculinity
they're they're you know i'm an eagle
scout they kicked you know they started
letting women into
to the boy scouts and it's like
masculinity came back even harder and
even more toxic or whatever you want to
call it
so i think this this censorship doesn't
solve anything in the long term
let's go to super chats if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and
share the show with your friends we're
gonna have a members only show coming up
at timcast.com uncensored at about 11
p.m so you don't want to miss that one
go to timcast.com sign up we're going to
read some super chats
all right ready to rumble says i touch
myself to your new song thank you thank
you very much
myself
i want you to love me
when i come you know thank you thank you
thank you you got it too i'll say this
like part of me kind of wishes we had a
subtle release of of the song and the
music we're doing um
we have to promote it we promote
everything and this one just
we've promoted all of our projects this
one hit harder than anything else and so
there's been this unrelent unrelenting
attack to tell us how much we suck and
how we're awful and we should stop and
we should stop and then i'm just
laughing looking at like the trending
and stuff and i'm like i don't know man
i think we got one you know like it's
better it's like we're inspiring each
other that you do your best and then the
people around you get inspired by that
and start to do better and then you see
that and then that makes you do better
and you kind of almost like are
competing to do your best
yeah man
misael fraga says republicans losing
ground as midterms approach fact
that's true
it's true uh the generic ballot was that
republicans were up by five points at
one point i think right in the aggregate
or something like that fell down to like
three maybe it was 3.5 i think it might
have been five but now it's neck and
neck and so while that doesn't mean
democrats are going to win republicans
are losing the polls biden's approval
rating in aggregate is going up and
you know when i tweet this stuff people
are like yeah well that's because this
that i'm like dude don't know don't care
when i tweet out biden's approval rating
hits rock bottom and aggregate people
laugh and say of course because
americans hate them when it's now up to
42 up like five points or whatever
people are like well that's because of
this that it's like no no it doesn't
matter why it is
you like recognize that he's improving
the polls and y'all got to get down you
got to get your messaging out there and
that means it's not just about going and
knocking on doors it's also about we'll
say it for the 500th time
building culture go play open mics go go
busk on the street go get involved set
up community events it's so important
man like if you live in an area you
should be going door-to-door and asking
people to come to like a saturday
morning event of some sort we've talked
about doing what we call saturday
morning cartoons where we invite
families to bring their kids to hang out
have pancake sausage eggs bacon all that
stuff and like a catered thing and then
we'll play cartoons that families like
approve of stuff like you know when chip
chiller comes out from daily wire we'd
show that kind of stuff just regular
kids programming and then people can
come and meet their neighbors and build
those communities that's what this
country needs
anyway
michael holder says totally unrelated
but it seems to me that the french
revolution caused the european nobility
to begin pushing the anti-self-defense
mindset that currently plagues the west
200 years of this later and you get
canada australia europe thoughts
oh ian you read a lot about that what do
you think oh wow i was thinking about
the french revolution beau marche you
know he he basically sold the french
king out to win that american revolution
um so you think that monarchies around
the world now are are are have have
evolved um kind of inoculated themselves
against like what happened in france
basically they're like we need to make
sure no one can defend themselves so
they can never stop us again but i think
the american revolution is probably a
better example
i mean they were trying to disarm the
colonists first
and so the colonists were like nah you
can't do that and then you know fighting
broke out
you know
interesting philosophy
all right
let's see we got here smothers235 says
your song is not that good get over it
well i'll tell you this i don't know we
wrote a song carter produced and
engineered it and we published it i like
it's it's you you can't gauge your own
song honestly like my favorite band is
metric and my favorite song right now is
all comes crashing and i'm like i wish i
could write a song like that but i don't
know maybe people like the stuff we do
right
ashboro says only ever wandered is the
joe biden version i'm calling on sheamus
we need you on that one
all right daniel vigil says tim as much
as you have been talking about tom
mcdonald we need him on the show break
the internet
tom has an open invite to come on the
show um you know he's he's
he's whenever he can whenever he's able
to i know he's a busy guy i've talked to
him i think a couple times now i'm a big
fan that would be absolutely incredible
and i think uh
we got to get him
and zooby on at the same time yeah that
would be amazing also i'd like to get
richie mcginnis and jack pasok on at the
same time we're working on it oh good
okay i saw them going at it on twitter
you saw me tweet it i'm right i was like
come over oh yeah i did i did i like
that all right roy rory f says tim if
there's an arrest because of the
mar-a-lago raid please have on cash and
myron gaines maybe raketa too if not
andrew from legal mindset
um i'd like to have cash back on and
talk about the mar-a-lago raid now yeah
i'd love to any time he's free yeah yeah
let's see uh okay uh gcpr says have tom
mcdonald on the show i mean dude tom
mcdonald should uh come on the show he
should yes here's what i was saying in
an earlier segment if every single
person who watched this show just one
episode went to downloaded itunes i know
nobody likes apple like i get it i get
it
and then bought fake woke by tom
mcdonald in one week he would appear at
billboard number one and there was
there's nothing they can do to stop it
and then they can all pretend but
something like that's the kind of thing
that changes changes hearts and minds
because you're gonna get regular people
being like
what's this number one song i wanna i
wanna know the number one song i wanna
be on the number one song i want to talk
to my friends about what's popular
but people just need to actually support
and buy the music and engage with the
culture
does do does apple have playlists that
automatically play the top songs like do
you have the top 10 playlist that just
changes everything i don't know
but i know that
yeah i i don't know i don't know why but
i will say like we're not on itunes
features list at all despite being
number two does it take a week or
something to update i don't know i know
that um it one there's a couple of
things it may be that you have to give
them like a month in advance notice your
song is coming out
fine
uh
i'm pretty sure john rich when he scored
a billboard hot number 65 with progress
and was on the top number one slot for
like a week and a half he also wasn't
promoted or featured and that's what i'm
talking about john rich of big and rich
you guys know this guy he's he's awesome
we've had him on the show he wrote a
song criticizing the rioters and the far
and the woke left and all that stuff
this is what makes them scared
because people loved it billboard hot
100 number 65 a song that was
criticizing woke people and wokeness
this is the stuff we need
let's get some more super chats
mark shepkat says in regards to not
getting any coverage on the billboards
you should interview or talk to tom
mcdonald he has repeatedly outsold the
competition and they refuse to accept
his numbers he has emails i noticed this
i looked up and saw that fake woke hit
number 96 on the billboard hot 100 but
he had five million hits and he was the
number one in digital sales and i'm like
okay that's bs they're playing games man
yeah so i'd love to see
i like it's this simple man if not me if
not the daily wi-fi anybody else just
anybody cracking through that system
when john rich did it it's exciting when
when daily wire launches movies it's
exciting when they hire disney
executives it's exciting if every single
person who listened to tommy tom's music
just spent a buck to buy that song one
time not only would you be supporting
his music and his ability to do more
they would not be able to deny that he
is a cultural force and then what
happens is let's let's step outside of
politics if every person who was a fan
of of heavy metal
bought the songs
it would chart because people aren't
buying as much music these days it would
chart the major labels would look at the
hot 100 and be like this makes more
money
start investing in metal and rock and
putting that on the radio so it's kind
of like calling the radio station and
requesting your song from like 30 years
ago that's what you would have done and
now it's you buy this song on itunes it
is 69 cents more expensive but that's
just the way that you chart songs the
way the way or or people listen to it or
any anything doesn't have to be itunes
it could be whatever service you buy it
from this is this is the fear i have
what is it like a thou for 100 views 100
listens equals one purchase one sale
like that it could be 150 but uh
nowadays people buy a subscription get
access to all the music and then the
algorithm tells them what to listen to
because that's me i put on like here's a
genre i like and the music automatically
plays
and so
like
that's just that's just how the how the
how the machine turns out these days
raymond g stanley jr says tim
i s uh why yesterday i spent over three
hours driving through rural pa knocked
on 47 doors and got two folks registered
i'll take two for my first time it's
just the beginning bro here here that's
amazing scott pressler is the king of
voter registration but voter
registrations predict outcomes people
who register to vote are more likely to
actually vote so if you all go out and
knock on doors that's really impressive
dude that's amazing it's awesome i'll
put it this way if every single person
who listens to this listen to the show
went and knocked on one door and said
you registered to vote yet okay cool
then you'd end up with a lot of people
registering registering to vote making a
big difference
j523 says please have on naomi brockwell
she reports on tech surveillance and
cyber security oh we'll take a look
check her out
all right notre dame says the wef is a
cowboy conspiracy to go back to the
1800s
i mean i gotta be honest you ever see a
good western when they're like on
horseback chasing after the train
it's a big cowboy the only way to get it
back we must go back in time that's
right unless we literally go back in
time
raymond g stanley jr says if we all do a
little we do a lot together that's right
uh kemesojif good name says tim please
pronounce corringe gene pierre's name
correctly she's our first black queer
press secretary it's corringe
i'm assuming it she makes him cringe oh
oh i see it
okay i'm excited for that project
veritas
expose that's coming out what is it
tomorrow yeah what's it about tomorrow
exposing the secret secret education
curriculum
i'm stoked about that
i think it's gonna be good
let's grab another super chat augusto
mimoshe says this message must be read
in every newspaper heard on every radio
scene on every tv i want everyone to
remember why they need us i love that
movie
chancellor suttler you guys remember
that you guys watch me for vendetta yeah
oh
so the chancellor is like i want them to
remember why they need us and so then
all the media goes nuts saying like
quarantine break and famines and drought
and then people are watching the tv just
believing all of this stuff
it's scary man
it's really scary too when you can get
someone in private away from the cult
and they start to break free that's the
real thing like get them away from it
get away from other people get away from
the social media and you'll see them
start to be like yes this sucks you know
but they're trapped
dr wolfstar says tim will never stop
hiding in his own echo chamber and won't
stop only listening to the sound of his
own voice and opinions why are you so
scared tim bro i just read your super
chat criticizing me for for being
uh
i probably listen to more critics than i
do people who actually like me to be
completely honest
you know positive criticism too
sometimes critics uh
critics will give you good
good yeah we've got we've gotten a lot
of good criticism and harsh criticism
and we've taken it and we've adapted it
on this show you know for sure
loc135 says tim i can't figure out how
to use apple music to download your song
i'm an android guy i love the show by
the way it's uh itunes is not apple
music and so that's why it's like really
difficult but you know
yep don't like that apple music is them
trying to compete with spotify itunes is
an app that allows you to download songs
and listen to podcasts it's really weird
because i think on the app it's mostly
just podcasts now and they're shifting a
lot of it's apple music or something
i don't know but like our podcasts on
apple music oh weird i think you can get
some
it's weird because this this podcast's
biggest audience is itunes
um yeah
i think the podcasts are on itunes i
don't really use apple music use spotify
i recently switched from apple to
spotify the only thing that like is
exclusive to apple that i really like is
they uh they post live sets
which is really nice like spotify you
can't find like live sets
from festivals or whatever
here's a good super chat from dr
wolfstar again he says tim is a cult
leader and lying to his audience oh my
but like the challenge i suppose is when
i say something like please watch other
shows you know what i mean
because like that's the only thing i can
really say like i get things wrong so my
best thing i would say is like listen to
jimmy dore he's a leftist but he's
anti-establishment listen to breaking
points with crystal and sagar and listen
to uh stephen crowder or whatever listen
to joe rogan yeah pretty sure cults do
the opposite of that and tell you not to
listen to other people and only stay
here
but that's the only game you got huh dr
wolfstar is to lie to people beanie man
battle yeah that's right ian kinney says
well that's the other thing too
it's the arrangement someone mentioned
to us the other day that's not trump
derangement syndrome it's conservative
derangement syndrome yeah and then i
thought i'm like actually it's just like
opposition derangement syndrome if you
oppose the cult
ian kinney says zuckerberg fled out lied
to rogan i got a seven day ban for
sharing the new york post's hunter biden
article which ultimately contributed to
my permanent suspension from facebook
aim you know maybe we got to do a
zuckerberg top facebook lawyer tim poole
joe rogan episode you know that'd be
nice
that'd be cool you know if i'm ever in
austin you know maybe
hit up joe or something i think so mark
kind of when he was asked if they were
censoring stuff they were like no no no
we have a company do that for us i'm
like what what's the difference bro
yeah that's the thing i think
joe's not as much of a culture warrior i
i would actually say
michael malus joe should have malice
with with zuckerberg on i think that's
my my advice to joe rogan is like if
you're ever going in up against like a
big shot and see if they're willing to
have a sit down and include michael
malus on it because because that dude
would do better than i would
in terms of calling out you know
facebook and challenging them and having
a good conversation about it bill ottman
would be a good oh yeah
yeah joe yo
bill ottman of mines sitting down with
mark zuckerberg that would be something
that would be something man that'd be
unique
yeah fiery [ __ ] conversation
mostly peaceful
roberto gonzalez says that's a good name
roberto we got a robert over here
roberto jr you're right tim america has
been falling apart for years now and it
all started after the 19th amendment we
should reverse that and get get our
country back on track
i don't agree
it's andrew tate typing is that what he
said yeah yeah
i think i don't think the issue is the
19th i think the issue is media
manipulation
but i do recognize that uh
was it 70 percent of millennial women
are democrats yeah so they're you know
for whatever reason they're getting hit
by more susceptible to media
manipulation or being targeted
specifically by it you know
well we know from uh like the the data
on depression that young girls are more
likely to get depressed from instagram
than boys are and it may have something
to do with being more susceptible to
social manipulation and pressures right
well we know that girls are much more
susceptible to the trans the whole trans
thing this is what uh
more likely to be irreparable harm
called that book that abigail schreier i
can never remember what it's called but
she wrote about it being us well
there's a a study from the boston
children's hospital showing that like
the majority of surgeries was done on
girls
all right whites have been taught to
hate themselves especially the women
it's mostly the woman because if you
come out and you speak out against a
you know a trans
man you get canceled you're not allowed
to have a voice the women
it's kind of like they dug themselves in
this hole you know it's like what do you
expect i don't feel sorry for you
all right nicholson lemon says has ian
ever read atlas shrugged i feel like a
lot of the questions he asks are
mirrored by situations in that book no i
never have read the book i i think
you're gonna watch part of them
yeah the three-part movie that's like
nine hours long yeah
that's terrible
no no just play bioshock
close enough i started that game i read
uh 1984 an animal farm those are like
the only two dystopian novels i've read
so far not fahrenheit 911 or not
fahrenheit 911. that's uh read
fahrenheit it's such a good book
fahrenheit 451 yeah exactly
trash panda says ian is on point tonight
straight 20s my dude back dog
it's funny though like whenever i talk
to people like i'll meet a fan and
they'll be like you know it's really
true like ian either does roll a one or
a twenty
that's great like but you extremists no
but you mineral attend too you know you
made that up didn't you oh no someone i
was explaining it on the show that a 20
in dungeons and dragons is a critical
success no matter what you're trying to
do because you throw a 20-sided dice and
a one is a critical failure no matter
what you're trying to do so it's funny
for role-playing like i'm trying to
convince you to follow me and i roll a
one it's like
yeah it's uh
you know whatever i want i dropped my
sword on the ground and i stubbed my toe
in the middle of it so so that it's a
meme now people will type 1 or 20 in the
chat depending on what ian says because
it's it's one of the other it's like
there's like sometimes people will
sometimes put an eight or you know i'll
see like another like okay that one's
actually somewhere i love when i see
like an actual like that's a 17.
all right three q h three quarters high
says congrats on the song tim my band is
interested in signing with tim cast
records contact me on all socials at red
pill fight club okay i will
let me fight club
red pill
fight club fight club
let's uh let's see what we can do um
we're gonna we got to invest a lot in
this man and uh we're gonna have to hire
more people and expand carter's
operation so we can record and promote
and produce and do marketing and stuff
and it's not easy and making money off
the stuff isn't isn't isn't easy
especially when the industry does not
like outsiders no joke
they'll do everything they can to try
and keep you out but you know what we're
going to make music because like the
making culture is the goal
so if we have if if people become
members at timcast.com part of what we
do is with our revenues invest it in
these projects and at the end of the day
it's a big marketing push for the for
the brand if we have successful hits and
stuff like that so we're definitely
looking to sign bans and then maybe take
some of the heat off
off of you know me and expand into other
areas for sure i think that's one
component of it too like with the other
projects we've done i haven't been in
charge like leading them and this one
was me singing so they definitely came
after me
politicus says or politicus there needs
to be a maga constitution and everyone
should sign it that would be interesting
what would be added to a maga
constitution um
like delivery
wait i don't know about that but i think
it would be like you have borders yes
borders are good like a defined border
must be defended
you know
an amendment to the constitution crazy
yeah repeal the federal reserve act i
don't know how you would immediately no
central banks yeah you need to
decentralize um what else jail hillary
clinton yeah that's the 30th amendment
jason
says wisconsin out here state gun laws
you can open carry shotguns rifles and
even pistols under 21 under 21 can own
open carry pistols but not buy them you
can use deadly force to defend yourself
if necessary statute 93948
well interesting
cam girl asuna says i agree there need
to be alternatives and resources for
people to seek employment opportunities
that are in line with their values i'm
tired of being forced to listen to
diversity inclusivity and equity equity
training and threatened when i say
something any suggestions thanks
you know
the reality of life is if there's a
problem
you must be the one to solve it and i
think a lot of people listen to us i
think the people in all this room are
people who are like i'm going to do
something that's why you guys report on
stuff that's why we do a show
and so
you guys just have to figure out what
you can do
i'll say this public square the public
square app is one of the most powerful
tools have you guys heard of this
you register your business it basically
when you sign up it asks you if you
agree with these values and it's like
american values like the constitution is
good things like that the family is good
you say i agree with these things then
they put up they put your business on
the map and people can download the app
public square and then they can look for
businesses that agree with american
value so you make sure you're giving
your money to people who don't hate you
that's great it's amazing that's great
that's one solution go apply jobs at
those places
you know not like it's going to be
perfect but hey there you go start a
company
or start your own company not always so
easy we've kind of kind of fallen down
the hole into this culture of workers
like everyone people think they need to
work for someone else but you know you
can start your own company macho man
andy savage says ian has won me over
with those nat 20s he's been rolling
tonight ian i found you to be pedantic
at times tonight you have been on point
with a lot of what you said oh thanks
dude ian's like if you riot death
penalty
in my room like how destroying someone's
home is one of the most abhorrent things
you could do to a human
really it's pretty bad yeah ian's going
to be sitting on the throne and they're
going to be like this man was protesting
and throwing rocks off with his head
that was his head that's a good
impression
powder pz says trump denied alex jones
request for him to denounce the vaccines
alex said he can't support trump unless
he does
interesting
lessa h says tom would come on your show
in a heartbeat i'll head him up hit him
up we'll try and uh we'll see if we can
make something like that possible you
know uh tom's a busy guy man like for us
to get such a big
like
big musician big celebrities doing all
these songs i would be i would be an
honor and a privilege man
all right mr grizzly bear says hey tim
all the post-civil war talk reminded me
about a show called revolution in the
show the government creates a nano
weapon that wipes out all electricity it
shows how a collapse might look
interesting
let's grab some more
super chits
triton 54 says it says a lot when a 17
year old has to stand up and say the
adults are back in charge those who say
violence is never a solution has never
been in a situation where it was the
only solution my response to that is
violence
in defense when you're being attacked
like kyle written as a situation he
didn't go out with a gun to try and hurt
people that's the lie they pushed he was
actually helping those people until that
dude tried to kill him so i understand
unfortunately yeah violence sometimes
war happens conflict happens
typically it's the solution when someone
aggresses upon you but i wish we could
get away from it somehow and and stop it
but the reality is this
if this dude is attacking kyle written
house the only way to stop him is quite
literally violence and it's not an
endorsement of it but if the police
intervened what do you think they're
going to do walk up to him like excuse
me sir would you kindly get on your
knees and put your hands behind your
back and he'd be like oh sorry about
that sir and then do it it wouldn't
happen what do you think this is
scotland no way where do they do that
ireland no i'm just kidding well that
was bioshock would you kindly put your
hands behind your back yes
yeah the dude's gonna be like no and you
see these these viral videos where
they're fighting cops and i wish this
wasn't the reality man but you know life
is just these things happen then we want
to try to avoid them but sometimes it
happens the age of roman aggression was
like hey we're tired of getting attacked
from our borders so now we need to go
out and attack everyone else around us
to take it over so that we no longer get
attacked that's when things start to get
really crazy where like violence is that
was that a solution i mean it probably
preserved the city of rome if they
didn't do that it probably would have
been taken over but
look at how many people died and sent to
slavery because of it don't uh don't
back a dog into a corner and then get
mad when you get bit yeah you know yes
defense should never be
criticized or attacked
patrick reichert says i want to let you
know that your song only ever wanted has
been a big help as i cope with my dad's
30-day plus hospitalization as he fights
for his life against cancer faith family
and your song sorry to hear it man that
uh your dad's going through that i hope
everything turns out well and i thank
you for the shout out and um i i hope
you know it it it's a song you know but
if it helps it helps
guy rainey says hey tim congratulations
on your original song and tim cast
records any chance of an album deal for
smokey mike in the god king are you
kidding those are legends
you know i i grew up listening to those
guys
yeah you know my mom was always playing
smokey mike and the guy king huge
inspiration to us by the way
obviously
i won't say i i will say immediately the
answer is of course not the daily wire
that you know that's that's that's like
all theirs all their stuff i will say
remember that remember that super chat
i'll just say that remember that super
chat yeah smokey mike and the god king
man
next level i mean together this is no
joke
uh jeremy boring and michael knowles
have a song under smokey mike in the god
king called together again
and it is legit extremely good i
remember
i heard it and then i told jeremy i was
like he's like he's like it was it was a
gag it was a joke you're doing it i was
like bro this song's really good it's
like a really good song and he's like oh
thank you and i'm like it's it okay it's
a joke sure it's a good song it is
together again if you haven't heard it
you should check it out because it's
legit and it's funny too they're like
wearing
band outfits and like like marching band
outfits and then like jeremy's playing
the drums and they're singing it looks
like knolls rated my closet that's great
it's good
it's really good stuff really good stuff
all right we'll grab some more super
chats here
uh okay i think uh richie mcginnis is
that is is that richie actually giving
us a super chat he didn't say anything i
don't know oh there he goes he says
couldn't pay 420 but get drew a a dub so
he grows his hair out
ian and i pick up on uh pick up higher
vibrations through follicles keep to
change you filthy animals yes let's go
swimming
richie
you ever grow your hair out drew nah
coming soon
says we are slowly winning the culture
war tim cast and crowder even with
censorship have grown in subs and yet
the young turks have literally had no
growth in the last 12 months well i'll
tell you this you know we were during
the 2020 election this channel was
growing like crazy numbers and we've
been we've been consistently hitting
over the pa over the past year like i
think like 10 000 subs per month it's
relatively low in my opinion if you look
at some of these other channels they've
been growing a lot more so we've been
trying to use what we have
to expand outward because i'll put it
this way
we should probably
be trending on youtube every night we do
this show
tim cast is the 16th biggest live
entertainment show in the world on
youtube the 11th most super chatted show
on youtube i'm sorry in the country in
the country
and you'd think that would be something
on youtube but it's not why well they're
probably suppressing us
so here's the funny thing
we were with uh the song we put out we
were trending number 23 on youtube and i
thought it was crazy because i'm like
we've had bigger podcasts than this
when we did the joke with the podcast
with joe rogan and alex jones we weren't
trending it's got 2.4 million views
because i my opinion is that they're
suppressing it probably because it's
politics politics it's tough as an admin
to to promote politics because if then
it starts to seem like you have an
agenda but if it's algorithmic it
shouldn't matter it's just like here's a
channel they got a big show people are
watching it it's joe rogan
but alex jones as well so we do a brand
new channel youtube knows nothing about
we put a song on it the song hits now
it's trending i wouldn't be surprised if
the next time we put a song out it just
for some reason never goes anywhere oh i
think the next one's gonna be bigger
well look dude i honestly didn't think
it was gonna
get as many views as it did
you know
and people are acting like i'm just
saying we're gonna put out songs and if
it gets 100 views if it's a million
views that's the point was like we're
just trying to make music i guess people
like this one i guess a lot of people
don't like it but dude a lot of people
like nickelback and a lot of people
don't like nickelback i think that's
what wakes people up though like if you
really think about it if you guys put
out another song
and it just gets like throttled it gets
destroyed it gets censored whatever
that's kind of like what people are
paying attention to because it's like
what does this have to do with politics
or this guy's personal politics it's
just a piece of art and i like it but
it's being censored not even because of
what he's saying but because of who he
is
and i think that's what people are kind
of paying attention i think a lot about
the in the nazi germany era they used
what was that musician that orchestra
really famous german
um
orchestra who was it was it possibly
mahler the only composer i can think of
no but hitler used like one of the great
german orchestration orchestrators and
like it was really popular the music
someone in the chat you guys got to know
this um and so
i don't know what were you feelings on
that he was supporting the nazis he's
creating phenomenal music
fogner
yeah this is this is an important one i
gotta read this w4 flower says look up
biggest industry screw job for tom and
there are two parts explaining what him
and adam went through with the album the
brave absolutely amazing album by the
way i read about that if you look up go
on if look up a musician type in
coldplay billboard and what do you'll
see you'll see coldplay hitting all the
billboard type in tom mcdonald billboard
and what do you get a dead page this is
why i was i was like specifically saying
tom mcdonald
when when we were when i can't remember
what was happening but we were talking
about his music and i said let me see
this dude's got to be billboard toppings
he's got 30 million hits on one song
it's like a gold record or whatever his
billboard page is got it's got no image
it's got no history and i'm like well
that's bs i can look up the chart
history then i saw fake woke was number
96 and i'm like what's 96 5 million
views in a week number one digital sales
bro the industry does not like outsiders
who can circumvent the labels so i was
like in my that's why i said earlier and
in this show like everybody just buy his
song make it undeniable force
them canine therapy inc says tim i
bought tom mcdonald single what's the
name of your single i'm a 68 year old
fan help me out it's called only ever
wanted to bite on itunes you got to
download itunes i know not a lot of
people want to deal with that or like
apple so you know i get it but i but i
do appreciate all your support
waffle sensei says first hearing your
song had an uncanny valley vibe because
i see you talk every day by the third
time i've heard it i could separate you
from the song
dad passed away a little while ago now
your song makes me think of my mom good
song man thank you uh thank you for your
support i really appreciate it man and
hopefully you know the song helps
yeah
all right let's see
andy ugaldi says i hope that you are not
using the super chat portion of the show
to interject your own super chat
question asking about one of your other
projects where you then spend spend to
promote it kind of not cool i don't know
what that means are you arguing that i'm
sending myself super chats to read them
that would be weird i'm kind of just i
kind of just randomly read super chats
and sometimes they're like offensive
when we get in trouble but i try i try
to screen them i try to read them and
then say the word after i read it it's
like a it's like a weird thing you have
to do dude you're batting like 999 if
you're that's what that's pretty
effective because you you're like
everything's really good the super chats
are nice and balanced so basically what
i do is i'll look at a super chat
sometimes there's like a pause because i
have to read the first three words
before i start saying the first three
words because sometimes like i get
caught up and i'll read something that
like i i can't read that like oh man
like youtube will ban us you know what i
mean
ganon 136 says i was on that show
revolution as an extra such a fun time
but the government and the military
faction themes are still sticking with
it 10 years later very interesting man
all right crab friends says it's not a
cult or fascism it's communist
bolshevism
perhaps
all right we'll do one more here rit pro
says tim if you're willing to shout out
a youtube channel i recently started a
let's play channel and i'm playing
through bioshock dude bioshock is one of
the best games ever you gotta check it
out it's like very it's like very much
atlas shrugged my friends if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends head over to
timcast.com and become a member because
we have a members only segment coming up
and it's going to get particularly
brutal and spicy because
uncensored not family friendly you can
also click the link in the description
below if you have the itunes player
it'll pop up and for 69 cents you can
buy our new single and um i think we
need to sell like a thousand or i think
maybe like eight or nine hundred singles
and then we're number one on itunes i
think that's the number i don't know for
sure she's up against britney spears and
elton john elton john and britney spears
re-releasing tiny dancer and i'm not
surprised we can't beat them britney is
back she's back baby britney but uh
if you don't like the song then you know
feel free not to buy it
that's how it works thank you so much
for your support thus far we're going to
be promoting until thursday because
thursday is the last day of billboard
tracking and we want to see what we can
what we can accomplish with this song
and we've got a bunch more to come drew
you want to shout anything out yes thank
you guys for having me you guys could
follow me on twitter getter and truth
social at drew h live
i host my show front lines five days a
week
on real america's voice it's actually
gonna start in about 30 minutes it's uh
nightly at 10 30 pm eastern standard
time uh so i hope to see you guys there
the links to my show are all in my bio
uh that i just shouted out on twitter
and getter and all that so thank you
guys
you wanna shout anything out although
yeah uh you can find my reporting um at
twitter just at all the buddhazone you
can find me on instagram and truth
social as well i just want to thank you
guys so much for having me had a great
time that was awesome uh you guys hit me
up at ian crossland anywhere on the
internet on social media it's probably
me make sure it's me before you commit
to it see you later thank you guys very
much for tuning in this evening with
drew and aldo i had a great time a good
time getting to know these two guys you
guys can follow me on
twitterandminds.com at sarah patrick's
as well as patchlets dot me we will see
you all over at timcast.com thanks for
hanging out bye guys
you